no no sería yo muy buenas tardes y no nos escuchaba escuchaba pero ya ya se
escucha saludos cordiales 16 minutos sobre las 6 de la tarde
parezco ya locutor locutor de radio voy a saludar por aquí como siempre
hola se me escucha para si alguien no me escucha bien muchos temas pendientes
vamos a ver por dónde empezamos estoy compartiendo la pantalla ya perfecto
esto viene luego esto viene luego esto viene luego esto viene ahora vale venga
vamos como siempre la sesión de preguntas bueno antes comentar aunque ya
creo que todo el mundo vio que subimos la revisión de apolo aprovecho entiendo
que todo el mundo aunque aunque ya desde el principio pues no todo el mundo
asisten directo a las clases pero que no que las vais viendo después aunque sea
con retraso tengo la impresión que hay alumnos que no se han dado cuenta de
que hay material subido aquí no lo digo por los últimos que habéis pedido que
eso ya sé que era verdad pero
arriba del todo en el disco del material hay cosas de que están también en la
teoría pero que estaban ahí en la parte baja no se veían también entonces todo
el material referente a la teoría también está aquí además del que vamos del que
vamos añadiendo las prácticas que como ya habéis hecho si algo nos dejamos o
falta algo pues lo comentáis porque es verdad que se nos ha podido pasar se nos
ha podido pasar he visto el mensaje aquí de
Juan Manuel vale lo miro esto lo miro vale esto que me comentabas no son
muy partidarios de subir que ya sé que ya lo he hecho ya lo he hecho pero claro
que al final no sé hasta qué punto podemos subir libremente artículos de
la revista entonces es una cosa que genera ciertas dudas pero bueno ya te lo
miro de buscar esto porque entiendo que lo diría en la clase esto que pone Juan
Manuel en cuanto a preguntas como tal bueno había un tema de Rubén este lo
voy a dejar para el final creo que el otro ya estaba no se había algo un
poquito más más corto lo es en él no sí sí compré no compré no si esto que
comenta Gastón esto sí lo hemos hablado bastante la en la teoría hay un
capítulo dedicado dedicado a ello es decir al final para acabar operando no
necesitas mucha mucha cosa referente a un computador pregunta es decir porque lo
normal es que lo acabes de haciendo en un vps online porque tiene muchas
ventajas de todo tipo entonces realmente no tiene hoy en día demasiado sentido
operar operar con el tuyo me refiero al algorímico si tienes que operar
discrecionalmente es otra historia pero algorímico no tiene mucho sentido porque
te va a bloquear un ordenador tienes entonces a no ser que ya tengas muchos y
aún así generaría dudas porque el web se te garantiza conexión te garantiza
internet es más fiable que tenerlo tú en tu casa o en tu oficina entonces al
final la operativa normalmente la vas a hacer en nube
entonces sí que para analizar y va a testear y esto ahí sí que necesitas
potencia de acuerdo necesitas procesador sobre todo y en general el que tiene muy
buen procesador ya lo otro lo tiene todo bastante bien si te recomendaría más
fijo que portátil pero por un tema de precio a nivel de portátil hoy en día
acabo de comprar yo uno y es bastante potente pero lo sabía mucho más y me
ha costado 2300 euros entendes quiero decir que esto mismo seguramente con mil
lo tenía en fijo mil o mil poco más o menos el doble a la alta gama la alta
gama se dispara mucho mucho en portátil y sobre todo ya digo tarjetas gráficas y
demás entonces normalmente si tiene sitio que la portátil pues tiene la
ventaja que es portátil al final tiene sus ventajas pero ya digo si no es
imprescindible que lo sea en fijo vas a conseguir mucho mejor precio vale mucho
mejor precio y sobre todo ya te digo por optimizar es sobre todo procesador
ya esto sí que ya lo he enseñado alguna vez cpu benchmark no quiero darle mucho
más tiempo porque porque nosotros miramos el procesador aquí hay otros
sitios pero lo miramos aquí vale tú coges tu procesador pero este porque
ahora mismo no sé cuál mirar el que tengo yo en este pc vale en este pc
que estoy ahora en usando tengo un y 7 12 700 no os fíais de las letras porque
hace más de 10 años que hay 7 entonces en esto no no no han ido a más no hay 37
que debería ser ya 27 salió o sea yo tenía el portátil que ha dejado ahora
tenía casi 10 años y 17 y claro puntuaba ahora vais a ver lo que
puntúa este el proceso el portátil antiguo puntúa 5000 y el nuevo puntúa
30 y pico mil y los dos son y 7 entonces día y noche directamente entonces ya
digo las el número y tal dice nada no dice nada entonces tenés que pues
venir a un sitio como este a que te diga que es entonces este punto a 30 mil
esto además está basado en en pruebas objetivas que de hecho podéis hacer si
tú vas a que los software y lo bajas en tu ordenador lo podrás hacer podrás
hacer y enviar el el dato que te dé a tu ordenador aquí a la web para que lo
utilicen en el histórico entonces este mío ahora es 12 30 el portátil es 33 ya
digo 30 es un avión recuerdo está muy bien ahí 32 gigas de ram un disco ssd y
ya vas de vale a ver el tema es en que era antiguo comentaba alberto que le
había le había contestado bueno lo segundo ya lo contesté si te refieres a
eso alberto lo contesté la semana la semana pasada lo que no es bar entiendo
que esto quedó claro si algo no quedó claro lo llámelo repreguntas en vale o
quien sea pero esto del open of next bar que es realmente muy interesante es muy
importante que no no lea futuro espera el tick de apertura para leer el precio
open la fecha y la hora de ese tick el tick de apertura y entonces procesa la
barra de cierre entonces no no no lea futuro sencillamente espera espera para
usar esa esa información vale y comenta alberto que sí que la
detecta un buque creo que ya es la segunda vez que se niente detecta un
buque alberto esto habría que comentarlo ya que comentarlo y ya va a ser en 2
alberto 0 en 2 alberto 0 bueno entonces esto de los de los bugs o
como queráis llamarle es pan nuestro de cada día en la programación y seguro
vale y lo que lo que seguro que enseñó y aún un buque tener también es normal
vale es normal al final ya digo es habitual con la cola esto deberíamos
detectarlo en la evaluación preliminar vale y lo normal es detectarlo en la
observación el gráfico y demás pero a veces pues bueno se escapa alguna
alguna cosa vale
vale el tema este que preguntó que apuntó primero rubén aquí luego lo
llevé yo al al bar vale esto es interesante es interesante porque
se abrió un debate ahí entre builders para quien no lo sepa era un que era es
un es un trade algorémico bastante conocido que también como iban
sherman ha ganado el campeonato del mundo de trading varias veces y que
está considerado pues uno de los grandes acuerdo en esto con commodities
encontraré varios artículos de entre él kevin davy cauman hay bastantes no
las de williams distintos pero más antiguos quizás a tener aún querías
mayor pero es más más modernos que que perry cauman o williams no y bueno pues
son grandes grandes estrellas del trade algorémico podemos decir vale que
destacan por su formación por el caso de kevin davy andrea hongar pues tienen
bastante bastante formación son conocidas conocidos por ello pero también
pues han ganado o bien han ganado el campeonato tienen operativa y demás no
entonces es verdad que andrea hongar al final sobre todo es conocido por sus
formaciones pero como digo ha ganado ha ganado el campeonato del mundo no es no
es fácil no es fácil ganarlo porque es un año de operativas pero pero sí que
es verdad que le pues es focus academia y de hecho incluso yo estoy dado de alta
y esa está un poco mi opinión mareante es muy agresivo es decir si tú no yo
pero yo os lo digo si yo no supiera que andrea ha ganado ha ganado el campeonato
supiera que es un meter porque lo sé de buena tinta no sé no tengo ninguna
duda de ello y pensaría que es que sumo porque su marketing es tan agresivo de
verdad es de los más agresivos que yo que yo he visto normalmente cuando ves
tanta agresividad con con la venta de cursos de material tanto spam tienes a
pensar que que no hay nada pero bueno ya digo que cero dudas respecto respecto
pero vaya que sí que tienen un focus venta de producto muy heavy están muy
muy muy enfocados en eso tiene un equipo enorme de gestión de la de la academia
además no y esto en mi opinión puede ser pero sólo puede ser es una teoría que
que genere un cierto sesgo no un cierto sesgo a la necesidad de siempre estar
generando contenido nuevas ideas no se tienen como un concurso además para los
alumnos siempre hay que estar como generando generando movimiento porque si
no pues no puede si tú si nosotros ahora por ejemplo nuestro imaginaos que ahora
nuestro focus cambiara y de pasar a dedicarnos principalmente a la
operativa decidieramos dedicarnos principalmente a la formación pues
claro habría que estar todo el rato generando cosas y habría que
seguramente tener mucha más gente trabajando para poder hacerlo porque es
que sería imposible entonces para generar el producto formativo pues hay
que estar todo el rato dedicado a ello y hace falta muchísimo muchísimo trabajo
vale entonces este mi opinión pues genera un cierto cierto sesgo él tiene
un método porque le ha puesto nombre que se llama andrea de hongar métod también
que viene y le ha puesto un nombre que al final deja de ser unas fases como
nosotros pero sí que el de andrea tiene una particularidad que ellos tienen unas
especies de librerías de filtros o de señales de entrada de setups y es
interesante no digo que que no lo sea es es interesante y ahí se abrió el debate
respecto a esto comentó primero rubén que lo estás viendo ahí que tenía una
base de datos y que le parecía un tema interesante a nivel de switch
su it es con que es que es cero ya lo habéis visto en algún en algún en
algún código nuestro si no sabéis de qué habléis está de que hablo perdón y
estáis empezando con con easy language pues os recomiendo como siempre utilizar
mucho el diccionario los que habéis hecho el curso de easy language que
sois muchos pues ya me habéis oído insistiros mucho en ello de acuerdos en
usar el diccionario entonces buscas aquí switch vale y verás que es vale
buscas aquí switch para más detalles le das aquí y te abre entonces esto esto
un switch sirve para hacer esto veis estos distintos es uno que es dos que
es tres dos más usando distintos casos y esta es una manera muy habitual de
probar distintos tipos de entrada y salida nosotros de mucho menos
evolucionado que esto que comentaba rubén enseñamos algo en la clá en la
5 6 3 la evaluación preliminar y dijimos que lo haríamos en la práctica y lo
haremos la práctica tenemos pendiente una práctica exclusivamente de eso
decidimos empezar de esta manera haciendo algún sistema y luego irá ir
aprovechando también las nuestro propio trabajo para hacer cosas como la
revisión de apolo que hicimos la semana pasada iremos iremos haciendo distintos
temas que complementa la teoría porque al final la teoría que queremos que
creemos que en general está bastante desarrollada entonces al final la
práctica lo que pretende es complementar añadir añadir contenido a lo que ya
hemos hecho la teoría y también pues el tener acceso a vosotros a poder
preguntar abiertamente sobre todo entonces haremos una práctica de eso en
la que evaluaremos señales centrales y esto se hace siempre con que es como
viste ya digo en el 5 6 3 hacia la parte final pero habrá muchas más habrá
muchas más que las que viste es ahí pero se hace así entonces pues bueno el
tema de un que él tiene un montón de setups y él lo va probando de manera para
mí hasta un poco exagerada
probando distintos y lo optimiza y demás no bueno es el tema de la o sea el
aspecto que concretaba y rubén ahora luego voy a mi respuesta y se abre otro
debate pero el el concepto que preguntaba de eso de del suiz para
probar distintas entradas que funciona y dice que para él esto es muy
interesante por si alguien quiere investigar sí que es interesante vale
pero más que investigar es un camino que insisto visteis en el 5 6 3 y que
veréis en la práctica es correctos eso está bien ya le ya en la respuesta
Juan Manuel le comentamos en directo el año pasado y el año pasado la clase
pasada que sí que eso es buena práctica que como todo pues hace falta
buen criterio y prudencia pero es buena práctica y que esto la evaluación
preliminar está bien de acuerdo ir probando distintos bueno aquí pone
rubén gatillos triggers o setups pues enfocarlo de distintos puntos de vista y
también pues porque no con las salidas de acuerdo se puede se puede probar con
cualquier cosa entonces ahí en mi respuesta que la movía el bar más que
nada por dejar limpio el tema de preguntas bueno mover o no porque aquí
no se puede mover si no la hubiera movido para tratar de sentarnos aquí
solo preguntas pero bueno la movía aquí al bar
aquí Juan Manuel no sé qué ha añadido luego lo miro y bueno le contestaba a
esto un poco esto que os decía ahora a Rubén y hablaba de los builders y ahí
pues no sé si quizá no me no me explique bien diciendo que es una especie
de builder sí sí que eso para mí eso sí que es una especie de builder en el
sentido de que es un buscador de acuerdo es un buscador pero es un builder bueno
de acuerdo se está mucho mejor hecho que un builder porque un builder al
final tiene millones de combinaciones de acuerdo millones de combinaciones y lo
reoptimiza todo y lo puede reoptimizar todo que también lo puedes acotar tú y
ahí es donde puede tener sentido builder ya lo he comentado en la teoría es de
tener sentido pero pero para mí es para mí el objetivo del curso que lo decía
aquí es una de las cosas que quiero dejar claras
es esta frase de aquí de acuerdo decía yo que lo que comenta de un guerra de
robert que esa es la máxima expresión el derecho de combinar un montón de
posibilidades y hacer un case que tiene una biblioteca enorme y que puede ser
interesante si se usa correctamente y si se tiene las bases para saber elegir
y manejar esa información y ese es el objetivo es siempre ha sido nuestro
objetivo del curso al final enseñaros a tener criterio pero el criterio al final
se consigue mediante conocimiento y práctica pero al final todo depende de
eso porque por mucho que todo sea objetivo o perdón mejor dicho por más
que tratemos de objetivizarlo todo al máximo siempre va a haber un grado de
subjetividad porque quien a quien decide es un sujeto aún basado en reglas
objetivas y esto lo veis en la lo explicado otras veces con muchas cosas y
es así quizá haya gente que se acerca al económico que le parezca extraño pero
si pensáis en la vida real veréis que no es tan extraño y lo lo podéis pensar
lo puse como ejemplo yo que sé el tema del covid por ejemplo con las mismas con
la misma información hay gente que defiende una cosa de gente que defiende
justo a la contraria y tienen exactamente la misma información entonces
y bueno y con muchas más cosas y bueno no digo ya con una imagen de un de
fútbol porque entonces ya nos volvemos locos es decir o sea hasta con un fuera
de juego o hasta con un con un con un penalti gente que dice que es gente que
dice que no es todo el mundo tiene la misma información disponible vale
entonces al final evidentemente esto es esto del fútbol es un extremo porque
además incluyen sentimientos pero eso vale tú dices pero es que hay sentimientos
ya ya pero es que el sentimiento si hablamos de ciencia o hablamos de datos
se traduce mediante sesgos vale y también los hay y también los hay con
los datos también los hay con los datos y también los hay con el hecho de que un
sistema sea tuyo etcétera entonces lo mismo que un equipo tuyo un sistema tuyo
etcétera entonces al final lo hay pero lógicamente con más información con
viendo distintas opciones conviendo ejemplos y tratando de hablar de ello
pues aquí no insisto los conocimientos y procedimientos adecuados pues se se
puede reducir a la máxima expresión que es lo que lo que intentamos entonces
aquí repreguntaba hablaba de que regresa por ejemplo es verdad que yo lo he hablado
muchas veces él por eso seguramente me lo soltó y decía si creía que era igual
que un builder y digo que no no es igual que un builder no es igual que un builder
de acuerdo al final lo que hace un geres bueno puedo tenerlo por aquí déjame
buscar un momento porque ha recaído con el código este que digo de las
evaluaciones lo tengo por aquí entonces a ver si era éste o era éste
pues no es ninguno de estos tengo aquí pendiente para hacer pero no está desarrollado tengo
una nada ser uno entradas salidas igual igual a este si un poco en este vale aquí tengo uno que
ya lo marqué el día para marcar y seguramente haremos más vales pendiente con notas mías para
hacerlo pero el que enseñé durante durante la clase esto es es plantilla con cinco diferentes
entradas estándar y 12 salidas aquí con esto le das un input y esto cada que es va del 1 al 5
normalmente lo ponemos en comentarios elegir de 1 a 5 salida a 0 elegir de 0 a 11 de acuerdo y
aquí aquí de un indicador para bueno eso es un código que permite pintar pintar directamente
el gráfico desde un sistema es un poco complicado no nos paramos pero aquí ves que tienes aquí tu
suite aquí eligiendo 1 o 2 pues eliges una distinta entrada o eliges una distinta salida
esto es un código de este tipo que él al final lo que importa es lo que hay en cada que es de
acuerdo pues pues para que me entendáis un que lo mejor tiene uno que en total pues tiene 100 y
200 de acuerdo que son todos los distintos setups y eso es interesante porque tú puedes
crearte unos filtros 10 filtros que tú crees que son potentes para tal te los pones aquí y los
puedes probar rápidamente a un sistema poniéndole aquí en el input 1 perfecto probó volatilidad
tal 2 probó volatilidad 3 de acuerdo es es buena práctica es buena es buena práctica hacerlo
hacerlo así nosotros un código como tal ya os lo dije no tenemos porque nunca hemos sido especialmente
amantes de los filtros pero eso también es porque nosotros nuestros la mayoría de los sistemas que
que hemos operado a lo largo de los años vale tienen un sesgo más bien de medio plazo también
los a entradía pero hay más hay más de diario que de entradía entonces al final a medida que
vas aumentando en diario que también se puede filtrar es más complicado de acuerdo es más
complicado y aunque por ejemplo un que sé que lo hace y otros otros lo hacen a mí me cuesta mucho
reconozco que a mí ahí cuando ya tengo un número de yo que sé inferior a 500 trades por poner un
número filtrar me cuesta mucho si ya tengo algo algo aceptable prefiero lo aceptable sin filtrar
que lo muy bueno muy filtrado y quitando la mitad de trades me entiendes entonces es verdad que
ese es lo tenemos y puede estar bien puede estar mal como decía que la respuesta no es nunca o sea
no siempre es seguro sí o no de acuerdo sí que sabemos cosas que no están bien pero a veces este
ejemplo que te digo yo es malo filtrar no no es malo filtrar pero evidentemente sabemos que
aumenta el riesgo es sobre optimizar eso es así ahora es malo no no no es malo filtrar recuerdo
entonces siempre hay esa se balanza no esa balanza donde tienes que jugar y a lo mejor pues si si si
si fuerzas un poco pues no necesitas mayor seguridad mediante más pruebas de robusted o más tiempo de
paper trading o a lo mejor paper pero probado con un lotaje inferior en real para ver cómo
va es decir bueno al final dependiendo de lo que saques pues tienes que jugarlo de una manera o
de otra pero no no quiere decir que necesariamente esté mal no quiere decir que necesariamente esté
mal no entonces decía que le hablaba le hablaba aquí decía que respeto su trabajo pero algunas
pruebas en que es que porque radicalmente mira hay una y esta esta me decía rubén que me pinchaba
que le dijera bueno a mí la metodología en sí para mí cuando él va probando y probando y probando
él tiene una metodología de en intradía como una especie de plantillas aunque él dice que por
ejemplo él no optimiza los inputs pero luego optimiza mucho las pautas entonces para mí sigue
teniendo el riesgo de sobre optimización en lo que hace lo que él hace de acuerdo es decir no
acepto que es inferior a modificar el input de un de un esto va más para rubén que entiendo que
que ha visto lo de lo de lo de húnger vale porque quien no que no haya visto pues ahora estará
diciendo este hombre que me cuenta pero entiendo que tiene más riesgo optimizar yo que sé una
media por poner un dato o el valor de la tierra si quieres vale que el hecho de probar entre 10
pautas distintas que detectan un patrón de volatilidad etcétera sin optimizar el input de
acuerdo que pero claro si tú vas constantemente optimizando utilizando utilizando al final para
mí también también tiene el riesgo no yo creo que él simplifica mucho algunas partes y algunas
aparentemente las quiere simplificar y también cae en el riesgo sobre optimización y luego la prueba
que hace de autosample pues para mí es demasiado poco lax es decir haría falta un perfil de
optimización para mí en la evaluación tiene una evaluación poco laxa vale me gusta mucho la
metodología de búsqueda de patrones pero yo luego eso lo llevaría a una metodología más convencional
de evaluación de acuerdo es decir hacerte un perfil hacerte un mapa etcétera el mapa aunque puede
parecer que no los hace los hace nos hace luego en una optimización lo enseña vale luego en una
optimización lo enseño vale entonces una de las cosas mira esto la tengo porque no sólo de esto
es esta y además no sólo de andrea ha hecho un montón de artículos sobre eso estoy totalmente
en desacuerdo de esto estoy totalmente en desacuerdo de esta idea que tanto él como esto lo hablé con
con ivan con ivan en no no no recuerdo no que no lo digo porque no recuerdo cuál era su punto
de vista exacto porque hablamos un poco de esto de tal y yo le dije que que yo no era partidario
él no no no me lo dijo exactamente pero esto para mí cae en un error tanto kevin davey como andrea
bunker que dicen que las pruebas que han hecho les sale mejor resultado usar esto fijo que esto
porcentual o variable para mi caen en un error absolutamente clarísimo que es una de esas cosas
que yo veo tan obvias a veces que no necesitan y ser demostrada pero parece ser que sí parece ser
que sí bueno esto es la semana que viene pero bueno como estamos aquí en el curso lo voy a
enseñar brevemente no no va a ser sólo esto la ponencia pero sí que una parte de las salidas
hablaremos de esto ahora la ponencia va a ser de salidas de acuerdo salidas entonces haremos cases
porque además trato de aprovecharlo todo esa información que preparo para robotilidad y la
daré de manera más seguramente simplificada y pero aprovecharé todo ese contenido para luego
hacer una clase de evaluación de salidas entonces al final hay que tratar de tener de tener sinergias
no pero una de las partes que me viene es este artículo que insisto he usado este porque es
de la revista de este mes pasado ya os lo comenté ya os lo pasaré de alguna manera vale pero el
tema el tema es que acaba concluyendo algo que ya sabía porque es algo conocido porque al final
nos conocemos un poco todos de cada el estilo de cada uno podemos decirlo y el estilo de
bonga y de que viene es que son contrarios a eso contrarios a los stops por centrales o dicho
de otra manera tampoco es que sean contrarios siempre dicen que les da mejor resultado de esto
monetario igualmente que andrea es contrario a wall forward y que bien es muy favorable a wall
forward de acuerdo es decir es decir que cada cada maestrío tiene su librillo y ambos son grandes
profesionales ya que al final espero que estoy hablando y no no busco entonces tengo tengo ya
una un pequeño detalle para que lo veis a ver visualmente en primicia porque esto lo en la
semana que viene haré la ponencia donde está universidades no es aquí no no es aquí
si lo encuentro robot 2.0 24 me lo tengo aquí guardado limitada pero si tenía un
workspace hecho yo de esto no se ha quedado es aquí a lo guardé lo guardé en la carpeta
digamos normal de no de la no de robo traer bueno muy breve simplemente para mirar esto
eso es un indicador muy básico para que entendáis el motivo y el por qué ya en
primicia antes de roboteider el por qué intento demostrar visualmente visualmente el por qué les
pasa eso vale a la izquierda creo que teníamos un stop en dólares 4000 vale y a la derecha
están por centaje vale más o menos bueno más o menos es el mismo activo como veis he tratado
de calcular el porcentaje que aproximadamente ahora vale me parece que es uno más o menos
aproximadamente ahora daría esto similares se ven al punto rojo bastante parecido a precios
actuales claro esa es la gran diferencia a precios actuales a más o menos valores parecidos veis
4000 dólares y tal desde el máximo desde el máximo anterior calmos desde algún sitio que
contarlo entonces desde el máximo anterior calcula una caída de ese valor de 4000 dólares o de un
105 por ciento vale entonces ahora están igualados vale y qué pasa cuando está rojo es que ha saltado
y cuando está amarillo es que no ha saltado vale es la manera visual de verlo vale entonces
ahora me voy separando vale y a la izquierda y derecha pues vemos poco más o menos cosas
relativamente similares relativamente similares si quizá aquí abajo se vea un puntito más pero
se ven cosas relativamente similares vale pero qué va a pasar si yo me voy yendo hacia la izquierda o
misterio aquí ya casi no saltan stops mismo valor 4000 dólares vale esto lo tengo lo tengo puesto
para que se me muevan conjuntamente aquí también saltan pocos porque porque no lo he ajustado por
volatilidad que sería otra sería otro otro debate por y lógicamente un mercado cista tiene menos
volatilidad y por tanto menos veces cae un 1 pero así como veis alguna vez cae aquí apenas tenemos
un esto aquí y un esto aquí en toda esta subida no hay ni una sola vez donde el mercado caiga 4000
dólares aquí en cambio como veis hay muchas y fijaros aquí en la en la caída que esta es la más
heavy de todas cuando vemos que ahí también hay volatilidad por lo tanto no era ese vector veis
aquí apenas hay unos pocos puntos y fijaros ahí como salta sin parar casi casi no cada día salta
cada día salta el stop cada día salta el stop vamos yendo hacia atrás claro el precio cae el
precio cae y lógicamente 4000 dólares veis la línea ahora lo lejos que está está lejísimos del
precio y por lo tanto deja de tener sentido entendéis sólo salta uno aquí y es que no
salta nunca cuando a la derecha sigue saltando todo el tiempo todo el tiempo porque es un 1%
todo el tiempo vale esto sigue sigue hasta incluso aquí en el 2008 donde es un crack como una casa y
ahí salta cada día o nuevamente cada día aquí ni salta a quien es alta el esto de 4000 es hombre
claro porque porque es esto no tiene sentido a ese nivel de precios exacto exacto no tiene sentido
no tiene sentido porque no se ajusta a la base del precio entonces claro que pasa si yo hago una
optimización como hace aquí en ese artículo el bueno de andrea concretamente que fechas usa usa
desde él además pone el 2008 justamente vale dice ves la diferencia hace esa explicación que
los hago yo dice son 4000 vale perfecto dice la lógica dice que sería mejor pero claro jaimito
con perdón perdona andrea perdona de perdona me andrea jaimito es que estás evitando que actúes
decir si tú le haces buscar al optimizador me entiendes si tú optimizas que lo hace vale no
no estás ecualizando no estás ecualizando el riesgo igual entonces claro que te va a salir
mejor este pero por qué te sale porque no salta en la gran mayoría de sistemas usar
esto es peor a nivel de profit salvo en casos donde no haya salida y entonces claro el salir
por ejemplo en el caso de bowling era hora de que veremos después veréis un ejemplo donde puede
ser porque porque no hay más que salida en límite de profit entonces claro evidentemente si a mí no
me dejas salir de ninguna manera y te pongo un esto pues mejora porque es que no me dejaba
salir en caso de fallo vale pero si yo tengo el la salida contraria del sistema es también el
lado perdedor imaginaros un sistema que sea un cruce de medias cuando se acaben cortando se sale
no pues vale a lo mejor no tiene un esto monetario pero se acaba saliendo no porque va yendo a la
contra en cambio si yo compro en la banda de bowling de abajo luego lo veréis y automáticamente
el precio sigue cayendo y yo solo salgo en profit en la banda contraria para que pase eso es muy
difícil tiene que rebotar mucho el precio si nos rebota sigue sigue sigue sigue perdiendo los
carlos en ese caso un stop suele aportar pero en la mayoría de casos donde la salida contraria no
es contempla también salir a la contra pues ya digo el stop suele restar vale suele restar
rendimiento en algunos casos puede mejorar los ratios de retorno riesgo pero en el mejor de los
casos el profit lo deja aparecido poco en la zona no hay una gran ventaja prácticamente nunca en
beneficio en gana en poner esto prácticamente nunca beneficio viene por el riesgo entonces claro
y no siempre es visible en ratios de retorno riesgo no siempre es visible pero entonces
qué pasa que en este gráfico de la izquierda si yo optimizo el stop de 1000 a 5000 por decir algo
normalmente me va a salir un valor alto porque porque me va a salir el valor que se ajusta a la
parte alta del precio no necesariamente a la actual a la parte que el precio esté más alto
vale a la porque si no imaginaros aquí ya salta mucho si le pongo 1000 es que ni abre entendéis
si yo pongo un esto aquí para que salte en la parte baja del precio es que ni abre es que ni
abre es que cierra abre y cierra entendéis entonces es absurdo este a lo mejor sí que
salta aquí en el 2008 entendéis este a lo mejor sí que salta que ni así cuida que hasta así le
cuesta pero imaginar esa idea no aquí sí que en el 2008 salta es claro pero le he tenido que poner
1000 y aún así fijaros que aquí muchos sitios donde no salta cuando aquí con un 1 salta entonces
simplemente es que no salta el stop entonces porque le da mejores resultados en monetario
porque salta menos simplemente por eso nos parece obvio a mí me parece obvio pues hay
muchos autores que defienden eso entre ellos andrea unguer o que viene el viejo de que ese
cajón si te poniendo este indicador ya lo ves claro aquí fijaros yo le he puesto 1000 ahora que
podemos decir que estaría más o menos tampoco mucho pero fijaros parece más razonable en la
zona baja de los precios que son precios que tocaron 2008 porque es que hace años pero que
en un sistema diario ya no te digo semanal tenía mucho sentido que lo cargarás hasta ahí no pero
claro a la parte alta ya es que fijaros aquí es que ni operamos casi no hay puntos amarillos casi
no hay puntos amarillos vale entonces ese es el motivo por lo tanto no es que sea mejor o no
mejor a mí no me da igual si es mejor o no es que es absurdo usarlo es absurdo solo tiene sentido
como ya os comenté era mejor en un sistema intradariario donde el movimiento entre del
precio no sea tampoco muy exagerado porque porque a lo mejor se mantiene en rango porque su vale
porque su rango entre el máximo y el mínimo no es demasiado elevado entonces puede ser que tenga
sentido pero no en un histórico que la mayoría es así que se haya movido mucho de máximo a
mínimo hay que usar porcentuala por volatilidad o cualquier caso que se ajuste al precio de cada
momento y usar un valor monetario andrea lo hace siempre así todos sus sistemas para mí no tiene
sentido aunque aunque te de mejores resultados aunque te de mejores resultados porque tú no
estás backtesteando bien tú no estás backtesteando bien para mí no estás evaluando de verdad si es
esto tiene sentido en el histórico o es que me da mejor el resultado bueno claro pues mira pues
no sé pues leía futuro y todavía te dará mejor sabes que si lees a futuro te da mejor pero no es
reproducible no es verdad entonces este es un caso típico de esto y entonces bueno entre otras
muchas cosas hablaremos de esta una de las cosas cuando me refería a una que no me gusta andrea
es esta esta continua persistencia casi usar esto monetario por más que te de mejor resultado es
que me da igual me da igual en muchos sistemas si no utilizas look inside bar backtesting también
da mejor resultado que es que no sé o sea al final hay cosas que pasan por delante del resultado
esto lo he dicho muchas veces cosas que pasa por delante del resultado no se trata de conseguir un
buen backtest eso es fácil yo lo he dicho muchas veces es fácil si me la pena todo como este caso
entiendes me da igual pues pues fácil no es fácil si se hace bien hecho pero pero si si el objetivo
es ese es muy fácil el objetivo es conseguir un buen backtest es fácil pero ese no es el objetivo
pues será era una de las cositas que quería comentaros por cierto ya digo el miércoles que
viene el martes a la clase pues el miércoles que viene también estaré en el robotrider vale venga
doy por cerrado esto el tema de apolo quedó claro no hay porque si alguien tiene algo que hable
ahora o calle para siempre ya si lo preguntáis disco le contestaré pero pero general ya digo
que dejamos cerrada la clase vale ya os deje el excel subido hicimos un par de cambios para aquellos
que seguisteis la clase bien vale no sé si era este el que tenía o no era este a ver si me parece
que sé que era este parece que sé que era que era este era este a ver déjame mirarlo porque
hemos tanto material ya que ya llega un momento que ya no sé ni si lo que estoy enseñando es
lo lo correcto o no es lo correcto el que subí como se llamaba no bueno no era exactamente este
esto creo que fue lo que hicimos nosotros después o antes ahora no sé si le fue antes o después
amigos pero voy a ver el material zona 3 no ya sabes que que abro este y está lo bajo es
es que ahora no lo encuentro o sea no lo cuatro bajo este y ya está y ese seguro que es es seguro
que es venga ahí está vale en fin por lo que os comenté hicimos un par así bueno comenté que
luego nosotros haríamos otra que era que eres pero ahora tengo tengo alguna duda perdónme de si no
lo he mirado si lo tengo preparado para serlo no puede ser que sí pero por no arriesgarme tal
nosotros lo hemos hecho otra con 30 vale que os lo comenté en directo que nos dimos cuenta que
el corte era un poco asimétrico en los tipos de mercado y vimos que probablemente era mejor
acortar 30 para ganar más más mercado alcista en la parte en la parte auto sample vale porque
había quedado un poco cojo de mercado de mercado alcista era un pequeño matiz no no cambia no
prácticamente nada pero queríamos verlo y luego también en la regulación de los incrementos
de acuerdo que sí que al final optamos por bajar un punto este a recordar que os expliqué que
viendo la análisis vi que había un salto demasiado grande y optamos por bajarlo vale está en la
nuestra lo hemos hecho simplemente comentarlo este ya estaba bien las mapas y las conclusiones son
interesantes y nosotros en el otro pues hemos sacado conclusiones bastante bastante similares
pero simplemente comentaros eso y daros cuenta que esa es la realidad que hay veces que pues tomas
una decisión a hacer una cosa lo bien analizando los datos pues para eso hay que analizarlos lo más
de la forma más estéril posible para no no capficarte no como se llama capficarte en castellano
hay que joderse capficarte es catalán pero no sale que sea lo que se llama capficarte
como se llama capficarte a chicos empeñarte empeñarte no ofuscarte ofuscarte ofuscarte
ofuscarte ahora gracias pili ofuscarte ofuscarte sería si no digo ofuscarte que
o sea no sabes como que no hay que y eso no es fácil tratar de ser al analizar la información
lo más estéril y tal oye pues aquí lo aumenté yo esto hacía en la revisión preliminar decidí
subirlo y ahora he vuelto a decir bajar porque pues la verdad que no sé porque ahora lo he visto
clarísimo lo hemos analizado y lo hemos visto clarísimo que tenía que ser 001 pero ya os digo
que esto pues puede puede pasar porque al final ya tratas de no sobre optimizar por eso en caso
de duda siempre mejor incrementos más altos pero también hace falta la suficiente señal ya que en
el mapa sí que se veía un poco aquí ya estaba bajado un poco pero estos saltos al final apuntaban
un poco en esa dirección apuntaban por apuntaban viendo el mapa pero luego había que ver que
efectivamente era así como vimos que habían saltos de bastante straights de un tic a otro tic entonces
esto ya lo doy por por cegado obsesionarte estaría bien joaquín gracias obsesionarte también vale
si es decía roben ahí de si había drop down relativamente iguales bueno pero es que el perfil
era seguro que no era igual puede ser que el valor absoluto roben porque al final el ejemplo
en ese ejemplo podríamos mirarlo algún día con algunos se llama nosotros en alguno lo he mirado
pero no lo tengo no lo tengo ahora listo pero sí que a ver si lo puedo abrir ahora esto rápido es
que probablemente sí porque al final el problema es que el otro se ajusta bueno tiene tiene menos
tiene menos con el fixe tiene menos con el fixe tiene menos con el fixe pero es que igualmente
no me sirve roben de verdad no me sirve a mí me gustaría ver el gráfico se había que ver que de
hecho para la parada botella ya lo enseñaremos aquí porque lo tiene aquí lo trataré de reproducir
exactamente lo que ha hecho en el sistema es que es que lo que te he enseñado en el gráfico para
mí es clarísimo es decir al final simplemente no es homogéneo no está no estás probando igual
que tú en el resto de variables tratas de hacerlo esa variable no se ajusta bien
o sea tu cualquier dato que usas al final está estandarizado porque yo que sé un mac un
estocástico un atr un a media móvil un doncha al final utiliza el precio de manera que se va
normalizando normalizando al precio de ese momento en cambio esa variable no se normaliza al precio
de ese momento luego lo puedes normalizar de una manera otra tú puedes decir que no te gusta
por dentro que te gusta más atr que te gusta más trailing que no oye pero un valor monetario por
sí solo no se homogeniza no sé no se normaliza perdón al precio no se normaliza y en esa imagen
para mí era muy evidente entonces es que a mí me dan igual los datos de verdad en este caso está
bien analizarlos y lo haremos lo haremos este ya digo tenía si lo hubiera leído para ellos
enseñaría hoy pero ya como el martes que viene seguro que ya lo tendré preparado para el miércoles
espero porque si no estaré a horas de dar la ponencia juego trader entonces os lo enseñaré
vale este trataré de reproducir este mismo y si no buscaré dos artículos porque este artículo
lo he hecho varias veces ya yo se lo he leído varias veces a él y también a que vendí me he
leído varias veces este artículo con ejemplos y tal y ya digo es que para mí es lo que te digo
al final en este caso se va a ajustar a uno de los mercados y dices hombre tiene menos de
hablar ya pero es que el problema es que este drawdown lo que habrá hecho es haber que fixe
le ha puesto 1100 vale bueno hay que ver el tipo de sistema lo que sea y en el otro le ha puesto
un 1 no cuando le he dado 2% no 2 y medio son valores extraños porque un 1% del nasdaq bueno
habría que ver cómo está calculado ya lo miraré pero 2% esto los a valores del nasdaq esto era
un 1% si no tengo bien calculado igual lo que con el mal pero el principio era un 1% y aquí está
hablando de mil dólares solo el nasdaq no bueno no es el sp es el sp es el sp que no cambia cambia
un poco cambia un poco porque 50 el punto cambia un poco habría que habría que mirarlo vale pero
bueno ya te digo al final el si tú optimizas el fijo se te va a adaptar a una parte del histórico
te va a saltar en una y en otra no te va a saltar prácticamente siempre te va a pasar eso no te
va a saltar y por eso va mejor porque como no salta y el esto acostumbra como te digo a restar
pues le va le va mejor y el drama pues el drama no en valor absoluto nuevamente ya digo que muchas
plataformas es eso la primera aunque multichars lo da en porcentaje pero aquí no vale en valor
absoluto nuevamente en un histórico largo así comparando uno con otro no nos dice absolutamente
nada porque depende en qué momento lo tengas es decir 25 mil volviendo al ejemplo que estábamos
antes pero lo ves un poco lo ves un poco lo ves un poco lo ves un poco no lo ves porque no lo
abierto pero ahora lo verás ahora lo verás vamos a hacer un poco de trampa para verlo
hacer un poco de trampa yo tengo esto un valor monetario vale calculado desde los máximos vamos
a suponer que yo a esto ahora le pongo línea le pongo línea y le pongo 20.000 vale 20.000 para
que me veas entonces tú fíjate a cuánto está del precio vale a cuánto sea el precio cuánto
está el precio no esto puesto 2500 no vamos a por 50.000 es igual por por se es exagerado
expresamente es exagerado expresamente pero es para que veas esto claro claro este de la
onda de 50.000 aquí no es el mismo que aquí es relacionado al precio no tiene nada que ver
no estamos de acuerdo aquí ya ni lo veo aquí ni lo veo no tiene nada que ver entonces el valor
absoluto en un histórico largo nuevamente el dragón no nos dice nada hasta aquí ni aparece aquí ni
aparece porque 25.000 es una locura de diferencia respecto al máximo cuando el precio está 5000
no tiene nada que ver lo que nos falta es que esto es el cómit estaba a 8.000 más de doblar es
más de doblar del cómit aquí entonces claro al final la referencia de la una sí mirada tampoco
nos dice mucho habría que verla en porcentaje habría que ver medio y habría que verlo el gráfico que
esto como ya os he comentado muchas veces es una otra es que para que no con algunos colegas
también bastante reputados que yo los he oído decir que no miran el código que no miran gráficos
de verdad yo alucino algunas cosas que los datos las medias disimulan mucho las cosas
las medias disimulamos las cosas que sólo se ven en el gráfico como esta por ejemplo el hecho
que el dragón sea 20.000 es muy bien pero 20.000 si lo tiene aquí es una cosa si lo tiene en el
2008 es otra cosa allí es un porcentaje abrumador a mejor de un 70 por ciento me entiendes y ahora
aquí pues es 20% igual estoy inventando totalmente entonces al final no tiene nada nada nada que ver
vale esto está estamos al día y de preguntas viendo nada lo que hemos hablado nada no es todo
vps ya lo dejo para ti eh pues damos un poco a lo que nos ocupa hoy bueno nos ocupa todo y esas
charlas yo bueno me equivoco pero creo que aportan mucho mucho valor bueno y os había hablado mucho
de las bandas de bollinger en el curso yo os dije la teoría nos dije que haríamos y os
dije que haríamos de los dos lados vale y lo haremos vale hoy vamos a empezar por la parte
antitenencial tengo abierto no tengo ningún abierto para que lo voy a dejar que se abra a ver
si nos revienta a ver si nos revienta vamos a empezar bueno voy a abrir voy a abrir este objeto
voy a abrir este que creo que tendré todo a ver aquí muy bien aquí tengo el que ya tengo abierto
pero voy a ir poco a poco porque instalar una versión nueva de multichars mira que multichars no
daba problemas casi nunca y ésta me está dando algún problema se me ha colgado alguna vez pero
cada vez no es la 15 que le han puesto y es verdad que quizá no debería haberle instalado debería
haberle instalado porque ya es habitual es una nueva es nuevo número vale de 14 y consultado a
15 y ahí sí que va bien un paro 1 o 2 de revisiones que entonces solucionan algunos más que de hecho
ya están beta también podía haber estado la beta porque seguramente hubiera ido mejor que ésta
la beta porque la beta seguro que la lanzamos rápido para solucionar los típicos errores de
cambio de versión y demás pero bueno bueno lo que os decía os hablaba de de bandas de bollinger
y aprovecho para enseñaros estas esto yo creo que sí que lo podemos dar alberto porque esto esto
esto es del siglo pasado literalmente es el siglo pasado literalmente veces del 98 yo creo que esto
ya no debe tener ni copyright no sé con cuántos años caduca los copyrights pero pero yo casi
estaría seguro que esto ya ha vencido el copyright entonces eso os lo voy a subir vale os lo voy a
subir esto está hecho de hecho en el easy language antiguos a que incluso hay algún código que no
funcionará como tal habría que hacer pequeños cambios pero bueno pero es fantástica esto es
una serie de artículos que hizo tres station que era un mega reserts de acuerdo y
pues saqueo a la misma empresa que hizo pues como una especie de
boletines que de hecho hay el trading concept que es así que no os lo puedo subir aunque enseñado
alguno en directo y alguna cosa subido vale intentó volver a hacer más modelo y tal pero
esto ya te digo esto lo tengo lo tengo todo es súper antiguo vale lo tenemos aquí todo y entonces
ya os lo subiré esto ya os lo subiré lo paquetaremos en un a ver cómo porque no deja subir de todo
veces el primero que aquí explica un poco de que va y tal era como un club como un club pero
está fantástico porque estamos hablando de 87 páginas habla de indicadores tipos de sistema está
muy bien a nivel de la plataforma es una versión mega antigua pero está muy bien la verdad que lo
que explica está muy bien está muy bien es muy completo y de consulta tiene al final habla de
todo tipo de indicadores y eso es lo mismo no hay muchas novedades en ese sentido vale entonces
estamos y nos lo subiré enterita todas estas ya digo cada una tiene se está en total no sé si
me va a decir el total de páginas esto no no sé si va a ser tan listo el windows ahora
decirme el número de páginas que tiene esto no no no está listo vale no está listo me dice que
tiene 20 megas y ya está no me dice nada más vale no me dice nada más entonces pero ya digo
pueden ser de 70 a 100 páginas cada uno así que ya veis que tenemos más de 1000 páginas de contenido
la número 3 hablaba de las bandas de bolíguer la número 3 entre otras muchas cosas hablaba
de bandas de bandas de bolíguer entonces aquí es como en toda esta biblioteca en todo este club
del estat pues primero pues hablaba el indicador lo explicaba luego pues explicaba un poco el
sistema vale entonces a raíz de él pues hemos partido vale para como siempre os dije ir partiendo
de ideas algunas de libros otras de experiencia tal pues está podemos decir que es súper antigua
clásica aporta nada en concreto ahora mismo está pero aquel que empiece que no sepa de qué de qué
de qué va nada pues pues un sitio fantástico para empezar porque además tienen y tiene una
cosa muy interesante que es revisar ideas antiguas como ya os he dicho pues te da
mucha fuera de muestra ya de empezar no y eso es un pactés de mucho valor o sea directamente
poner el sistema como está y ponerlo que no va a este por ejemplo pero imaginaos que contas uno
que va que a veces encuentras hostia tienes un auto sample bueno más que un auto sample en ese
caso es un for war testing para mí aunque también hay otros que dicen que no pero para mí eso es
un for war testing como una casa de fantástico hay que revisar bien que no lea futuro que sea
reproducible todo que sea bien vale revisarlo bien pero si conseguimos eso y el sistema funciona
sin ajuste en hacer la optimización y nada imaginaros sacas un montón de años de for war testing
que te dan muchísima tranquilidad para ir a operar con el sistema y eso pasa eso pasa vale entonces
además esto incorpora una cosa que no vamos a perder mucho tiempo vale pido por favor voy a
explicar lo que hace una función que se llama m ro y el 80% el 80% o el 90% de el que lo va a
oír sea en directo sea después no lo va a entender no lo va a entender y por su cuenta
tendrá que entenderlo vale a ver podemos explicar lo explicaré un par de veces para el 3 lo
enseñaré la ayuda y tal vale pero eso no es curso de programación esa función sale en el curso
de ese lenguaje creo que en el inicial no quiero y también sale en el máster pero creo que ya
salen inicial al final y siempre es una clase los que te hayas hecho ya el lenguaje ya os ha salido
así que seguro que ya se os ha se os ha atragantado allí y bueno a lo mejor al final pues en la
explicación con un profesor de extrema calidad y lenguas como yo pues seguro y modesto entre muy
modesto pues lo entendiste vale vale entonces vamos a ver la versión inicial a ver en qué aquí no
tendré el inicial lo metido espérate que en este a ver por qué tengo aquí tengo aquí yo creo
que en el en el del en el del ese en el de brostox lo he dejado metido lo dejamos a ver si no no se
nos cuelga y todo va bien de verdad voy a enseñar el código y a partir de ahí vamos vamos tirando
vale todo esto si si no se lo meto ya está ese es un poco el original esto hoy no lo
tenemos listo en pdf pero lo pondré entonces bueno la versión la versión principal que
la revista bien explicado también os la pondré al final es un sistema que si lo vemos en la
pantalla de manera general ahora veremos entraremos en el detalle pero de manera general compra
este yo creo que sí que tiene a ver dónde está el ballinger bans uno bolígar normal es este vale
es este lo que valores tengo puesto yo aquí a ver qué valores tengo puesto yo aquí vale tengo 14
tru tru un long un short al pin 4 3 salobo stop no y filter a et filter tengo 18 pues lo voy a
no filtro de momento sin filtrar perfecto es en su ver ellos lo hicieron piramidando vale es decir
que añade nos da igual eso ahora mismo simplemente para que hemos respetado un poco la lo que ellos
lo que ellos hicieron vale lo que ellos hicieron ballinger bans ballinger bans close close si
se acumula close 14 entonces esto que hace esto que hace esto hace que cuando hay un cierre por
encima de la de la banda vende básicamente y cuando cuando hay un cierre por debajo compra
pero pero esto hay muchas maneras de abordarlo muchas maneras de abordarlo y vamos a dar algunas
ideas de unos consejos y para que cada uno explore vale esto vamos a operar bandas de ballinger
de manera en reversión de acuerdo que es la más habitual diría y ya digo funciona en general
bastante bien por ejemplo en el lado largo de bolsa es espectacular es espectacular en cualquier
activo le metes un sistema de compra normal y corriente nada nada y vender en la banda de
arriba lo vais a ver y ganar bastante dinero es decir en un sistema muy sencillo y muy bueno de
acuerdo es decir poco este trade poco se trae el que veis aquí es bastante habitual es bastante
habitual este tipo de operativa hay que ver aquí en qué rango que tal pero estos euros stocks que
tampoco es que sea especialmente bueno pero ahí está vale pero tiene una particularidad aquí
hay varias maneras de abordar la banda de bolígina una que lo voy a poner aquí entre eso que ya me
ha cargado a ver cuál tengo aquí tengo el uno aquí tengo el uno entonces tengo el uno perfecto
pues no era este tampoco bueno es igual se lo voy a meter yo a uno y bomben y barca y barca
a ver cuál de estos tenía que estar más en forma este está muy bien este vale pues me lo voy a
meter en este de aquí de la derecha y acabaremos pues muchísimo antes a ver cómo se llama esto
está está está toco solo he puesto esto delante hemos puesto curso este está de
parece si si si ya lo veo está 23 perfecto este es el está el está desactivo el 0 1 y este lo dejo
bueno mira lo voy a dejar en su versión original para explicaros el explicaros el robo el en su
versión original creo que lo metía en cinco minutos no lo has probado eso no creo que lo
metía en cinco minutos en el sb si no lo ha probado eso no va a ir pero bueno lo voy a probar voy a
probar a ver dónde lo ponían de fin de tal tal tal tal para ti para tapar poder pues posteo que
lo veo ahora yo que yo me es una crea aquí que aquí saldrá sb h esto que es sb cinco minutos en
el sb debía ser el índice cinco minutos en el sb pero la verdad que no lo he probado y bueno
tengo puesto aquí el original con 10 vale pues vamos a poner las bandas de bowling en 10 y así
veremos el claro de esta manera tiene que ir bastante rápido más piramida piramida
piramida pero es que opera poco porque por la por la función mro ahora se explica la función
mro sirve en este caso para contar el número de veces que cierra por encima por debajo de la banda
pero lo hace de una manera que a veces no es del todo intuitiva porque es negándola un poco vale
esto como siempre es muy utilizado esto siempre para contar casos en el para contar cosas digamos
es muy utilizada y casi siempre se usa por pasiva me explico mejor vale es decir lo que lo que
analiza la función mro es de las siglas de most resen occurrence aunque en realidad puede medir
cualquier ocurrencia la más resen la primera la segunda etcétera eso se controla con el tercer
parámetro de la función la función tiene tres parámetros 1 la señal que evalúa es decir el
test que hace el true false que puede ser cualquier cosa que yo evalúe en este caso es que el cierre
sea mayor igual que la banda menor igual lo que yo quiera vale lo que yo estoy evaluando o sea que
es la prueba que hace es esta cierre mayor o igual que banda baja en este caso vale luego el otro
parámetro de los tres que tiene bueno mira como lo veis es que no lo vais a ver ahí no lo vais a
ver ahí porque es muy es muy pequeño no lo vais a ver en el diccionario es muy pequeño así creo
que lo podremos ver un poco vale de los tres de los tres aquí de los tres parámetros que tiene
primero el test el número de barras que lo evalúa esto es un parámetro del sistema que ahora por
efecto está en dos aunque como funciona mejor es en uno luego lo veremos y el tercer valor que
casi siempre está en uno pero esto es lo que evalúa que instancia es decir si es la más reciente o la
segunda más reciente la tercera más reciente normalmente es la más reciente vale y también
está la función lr o que es la list resenocorrencia es la más reciente la menos reciente de acuerdo
es un poco más y esta no me consta haberla utilizado pero pero pero es lo que os digo
está esta función es una canción que cuando tú la consultas le dices a ver cuando ha cerrado por
encima de la banda en las últimas tres barras vale y te devuelve el número de barras que hace
que eso ha pasado entendido es decir si me devuelve 0 es que ha pasado en la actual si me devuelve 1
es que ha pasado en la anterior si me devuelve 2 es que ha pasado hace dos vale y si me devuelve
menos uno quiere decir que no ha pasado y eso es lo que normalmente utilizamos es decir lo miramos
por pasiva es decir yo me interesa mirar cuando da menos uno es decir cuando no ha pasado una
determinada cosa en unas determinadas barras en este caso yo le digo el cierre está por debajo
de la banda alta vale está por debajo de la banda alta en las últimas dos velas entendéis está
por debajo si me devuelve que no que quiere decir que ha estado por encima que es lo que a mí me
interesa vale entonces por qué se cuenta por pasiva porque yo así puedo contar varias barras
porque el saber cuando ha pasado algo sólo es una entendéis también podría hacerla más complicada
sería análogo y hacer m ro en la barra anterior y la barra anterior si dos funciones de m ro que
no valieran menos uno sino que valiera cero y que valiera uno en la barra actual sería cero para
que se va a programación el que no no salía o sea hay otro se puede hacer con dos funciones
m ro lo mismo pero cada vez más eficiente hacerlo sólo con una entonces esto verifica eso verifica
que no ha pasado algo en n barras qué utilidad tiene pues eso que yo puedo ponerle 5 si quiero
vale y lo que lo que va a hacer es que las últimas 5 no haya pasado claro entonces no va a operar
no va a operar pero yo le voy a poner 5 vale iba a hacer muy poco o sea o ninguna igual no sé si
alguna vez ha estado cinco veces por encima de la cierre por encima de la banda es muy complicado
es muy complicado porque bolinger siempre vuelve el precio pero bueno vamos a ver si ha pasado
alguna vez bueno podría haber algo no ha pasado pero ha pasado una vez ha pasado una vez no ha
pasado no ha pasado porque porque pita y verlo sumersión y está en cierre seguro vende aquí
bueno esto es por el max bar creo no efectivamente es un es un es un error esto a veces en el código
en algún tipo de indicadores tenemos que utilizar curren bar para para ver cuando estabiliza
indicadores que no estabilizan las bandas de bolinger aunque hay estén bien pintadas
todavía no deben estar bien calculadas porque no hay tutías es decir no puede vender ahí no
puede vender es porque algunos están estabilizadas no están dando cálculo correcto seguramente eso
pasa con algunos indicadores al principio de los gráficos pero bueno en definitiva se entiende
la idea no yo busco por eso aquí prácticamente lo pasa si le pones tres por ser a tres al final
lo dejamos otra vez en dos que es como estaba por defecto esa es un poco la versión de
que mira ya que era como estamos poco probando lo alberto ya que hemos visto que lo probaba el
índice sp lo que vamos a hacer es probarlo en el como decían en 5 o 6 meses no porque
si no vamos a ver nada más que nada es curiosidad a ver qué hace esto ahora resulta que que va a
ir bien y todo la verdad que lo veo poco probable eso es como estaba como estaba definido con dos
cierres estaba así definido para asegurarme si sólo tiene los dos nosotros he puesto yo 10 cierre
10 menos 2 menos 2 y en dos barras dos barras y la salida en tres en tres veces y aquí en 4 4 3
esto lo he puesto yo como inputs pero lo he dejado lo he dejado como estaba por defecto 4 3 en menos
4 segundos 3 eso es 4 3 desviación como desviación a eso la desviación de la banda a coño pues ahí
estaba el fallo ahí estaba el fallo antes es debe ser pero es que yo lo tenía puesto aquí en 2 eso
no sé qué es eso me va a haber equivocado el sistema voy a quitar el otro va a quitar este ahora
estaba estaba estaba estaba que decía yo digo si no me sonaba haber postos y es 2 2 4 3 a low
stop cero y cero no es el vaca aquel no que dijimos hay un baño tres de verdad esto esto
es esto es pero bueno ahora va bien no entiendo que me ponga así entiendo que si esto va añadiendo
y cada vez que le produce si no cierre añade porque aquí cierra pero bueno esta es la versión
original que la verdad que francamente le doy pocas opciones pero pocas opciones pero
bueno esa era la versión original 15 15 es mucho no 15 es mucho no alberto bueno lo dicho vale
con el mos resen ocurrens controlas un poco eso entonces maneras de tratar la banda la banda
de bollinger la más habitual es trabajar el cruce pero éste estaba el original el mos resen y pues
he preferido dejarla para que la para que la vierais vale para que la veas nosotros hemos
hecho la versión donde hemos incorporado algunas otras cosas partiendo de esa de esa misma vale
donde el setup de de largos cortos simplemente hemos mantenido la función m ro porque el m ro
si le das un valor 1 si le das valor 1 es lo mismo que cerrar por encima por debajo de acuerdo
entonces lo hemos dejado se podía haber quitado pero lo hemos dejado pero le hemos añadido
además lo que pasa es que así va a quedar un poco lioso de entenderlo pero creo que se va a
entender es decir lo que hemos añadido es que el mos resen ocurrens no lo evalúe en la barra actual
sino en la anterior vale y que en la actual haya cruzado al alza vale sólo con sólo con el cruce
ya ya ya se puede hacer de acuerdo ya se puede ya se puede hacer es decir realmente es rebundante
de hecho si lo piensas no no aporta el mos resen no no aporta nada porque el cruce en sí el mos
resen si le das valor 1 no aporta nada lo podías borrar del código y no haría nada vale porque
me paso ahora al otro vale que era este por ejemplo o este vale porque no hace nada porque el cruce
lo que está evaluando es esto está evaluando exactamente esto es decir que la que en la anterior
esté por debajo pero que vuelto a caer en lo de que no se ve el gráfico no ya se ya se está
aguanta esto es corte vale al final tres sesiones indicado el compuesto se ha comparado el compuesto
que te evita hacer que el anterior usted cierre por debajo y el actual por encima eso es cross
under cross under y acceso pero si no lo haces entonces si tú haces cross under por narices
para ser true la anterior tiene que estar por debajo por lo tanto es rebundante mro el mro
puede tener sentido poniéndole 2 pero pediéndole 2 es muy exigente puede tener sentido de mejor en
un intradiario no activo además extremadamente volátil que se salga mucho de las bandas puede
tener sentido y por lo tanto no está mal dejarlo porque te permite esa configuración pero ni mucho
menos el ebro stock se encaja con este tipo de activo que es bastante pesado vale pero aun así
ya digo debería de ser de esa manera si le fuerzas tanto lo que vas a tener que hacer es
bajarle mucho el si yo aquí le pongo que tenga que hacer 2 al 0 1 es lo poco que opera yo tengo
cargados aquí tengo cargado desde 10 años tengo cargado 10 años y he hecho 63 y solo por eso
pero es como yo le pongo ahora uno es igual el resultado que no me importa ahora en este
en este momento ya lo le pongo uno aquí y veréis cómo se va a multiplicar probablemente por
bastante más más de doblar va a hacer seguramente es un poco más de doblar 141 ha hecho más del
doble trade para añadirle una una barra que ahora sigue teniendo dos condiciones bueno el
cruce son dos la barra anterior y la barra actual barra anterior y barra actual pero es lo que os
digo si yo esto lo llevo otra manera es decir bueno pues yo le quiero dejar dos vale le quiero
dejar dos ya faré porque quiero dos siglos quiero una una sobreventa bestial que el mercado ya ha
caído como un animal entonces exige dos pero entonces ya pues a mejor a mejor la banda esta
de 5 me lo estoy me lo estoy inventando o a lo mejor la desviación de que sea más estrecha
para lógicamente las bandas de bollinger poniéndolo más bajo no va a cerrar más
es porque siempre se van a adaptar al precio siempre recoge la normalización del precio
entonces no no se va no va a saltar más al revés va a saltar hasta menos lo que
habría que hacer es bajar el la desviación tip la desviación típica de acuerdo habría
que bajar la desviación típica pero se tiene un poco lo quiero decir no es decir que si al
final tú le obligas a más cierres a lo mejor tienes que reducir que se acerque en que la
volatilidad que le pides no sea tanta entonces ahora mejor sería más sería más bajando la
desviación aquí pues poniéndole 1.5 a generarse 1.5 es como ahora ya pasa un poco más seguirán
habiendo poco estrecha porque pedirle dos cierres por debajo no es fácil pero evidentemente como
veis ya aumentó bastante más la operativa y aumentó bastante más la operativa donde
ahora aquí le he puesto 10 y aquí le he puesto 1.5 y aquí menos 1.5 ahí se ve 1 2 y vuelta veis
aunque parece rara pero pero es así lo veis no un cierre fuera otro cierre fuera y el siguiente
tiene que ser en principio siempre así un cierre fuera por poco un cierre fuera para dentro compra
cierre fuera cierre fuera el siguiente dentro compra aquí es un luego lo veremos es un tipo
de sistema donde filtrar por adx suele aportar suele aportar porque porque ese tipo de entradas
cuando la de que se empieza a sumar puede puede saco de evitarte de entrar puede evitar que ver
qué valores y demás pero pero ya digo es es un es un indicador donde puede puede puede tener cierto
valor cierto valor aquí lo normal es trabajarlo en el mismo en el mismo periodo para no añadir
inputs entonces ahora que la de que esté por encima del determinado valor hay que ver cuál decir oye
no jugamos no jugamos incluso también funciona muy bien los mil reversa del filtro a la contraria
es decir aquí podían funcionar los dos decir que tuviera una franja de trabajo de acuerdo es decir
ni muy abajo ni muy arriba es decir a tener una una una franja que no te interesa no te interesa
es decir porque te interesa que que la de x no esté no esté muy movido es donde es más probable
que vaya bien pero cuando el mercado para las a nivel de entrada de acuerdo sea aquí me explico
eso es un poco podemos decir experiencia vale aquí es donde normalmente es más probable que yo tenga
un mercado adecuado vale pero si lo que busco es eficacia de entrada normalmente en los mil
reversion se suele encontrar problemas identificarlo aquí entiendes decir se suele encontrar aquí
cuando ya ha habido expansión el problema es que eso cómo lo identifico porque aquí también la
equidad entonces bueno un truco aquí lo hemos hecho así bajando pero yo creo que el mejor filtro
puede ser doble aquí en ese sentido usando de que sea usando este para entrar pero también que
no esté demasiado alto que no sé demasiado hay que hay que verlo hay que ver bueno lo veremos entonces
esto ya os digo es una una una variación de la de la entrada ahora vamos a ver las distintas
opciones que tenemos para la salida pero ahora por ejemplo si esto mismo lo volvemos a pasar a
cinco minutos y le cargamos vamos a pasar a cinco minutos 10 lo dejado sé cómo estaba así puede
ser que sí que me estoy operando demasiado mejor aquí sí que ya no necesito dejarlo y medio bueno
ya digo esto es lógicamente hay que hay que investigarlo pero sería otra otra opción son
lo estoy mirando ahora por primera vez en cinco minutos y no nos pensé es que lo hemos
trabajado muchos pero este no es lo comentado ahora para para verlo por por curiosidad porque
era un poco como lo había definido el autor pero aparte que leo los stocks ya os digo que si no
me parece no mejor aquí a ir al otro extremo vamos a ir al otro al otro extremo la verdad que aquí
la sensación que da es que opera bastante que da es que opera bastante así que igual aquí ya
le vamos a quitar que tenga dos y no tenemos salir de lo que tenemos es salir original true
mira le voy a poner salida original false luego se salir en la banda y así ya os introduzco el
otro caso típico de salida positiva de bolígara bolígara en tendencia vale que es salir en la
banda contraria vale eso es un poco la entrada típica la entrada típica de este es un ejemplo
clásico de operativa que está con dos esperamos que la banda no ahora no sé creo que lo dejado
con dos y estos dos y van en dos entonces aquí lo tengo que poner en dos que lo he removido esta
es ahora esa es la típica entrada que os decía de bolígara que sobre todo en el lado largo
pues suele dar resultados bastante bastante buenos aquí por lo que hemos visto no no gana
dinero porque no tiene salida lo que decía vos os decía antes claro ese es el ejemplo claro que
os decía es en un sistema si esto va a añadir 100% porque no puede salir solo sale hasta que
vuelva entonces es demasiado va a tener enganchadas y imaginaos el lado corto a tener algunas
por lo saca casualmente es en el lado largo pero va a tener algunas pero claro en el lado largo
pero por las caídas en el corto también porque el mercado va a subir va a subir y va a tener como
enganchadas considerales a fin de día está pensado para para eso quizá aquí para operarlo así
sería mejor operarlo en el nq continuo y hasta si vas continuo pues te quedas ahí y hasta pero
es realmente para que veáis el clásico setup anti tendencial de bolígara vale este es el clásico
setup que cierre por debajo aquí tiene el componente del mro que ahora está actuando porque está en dos
pero que lo podemos quitar lo podemos quitar ahora lo vamos a quitar estamos aquí bueno no sé
ni cómo ser de comisiones igual estoy aquí súper estoy aquí super metido de comisiones
bueno seguimos con el 15 no viajan entonces pero bueno sigue siendo muy alto pasa vale y
pues bueno todavía digo es bastante pasante churro en 5 minutos porque no estaba como os digo
y estudiado ni ningún tipo de optimización simplemente que el autor aquí lo había puesto
cinco minutos pues bueno vamos a vamos a ponerlo pero me parece demasiado sencillo para un 5 para
un 5 minutos que ya se ve que sé que hay setups que tienen cierto que hay entradas que tienen
cierto sentido aquí incluso jugando de asumiendo que dejamos esto en 10 2 2 y su salida bueno que
la salida original suya la verdad que metido así metido así podría ser podría ser que aportar
porque se le va a permitir salir a los malos también es que va a permitir salir a los malos
entonces no aporta porque te sale te saca de los malos pero te evita te evita tener tener
bastante recorrido con los con los buenos algunos tiene pero la mayoría salen antes de llegar al
a la buena entonces y de poco straight realmente largos vamos a seguir evolucionando lo vale bien
lo que os decía en su versión más convencional que podemos tener es salida a la media lógicamente
un stop un stop que podemos regular que está lo voy a dejar en 1 y esto lo vamos a subir a 14
por usar un valor así más más clásico número de cierre es 1 esto me da igual porque la he anulado
la desviación la dejo en 2 por defecto es decir de momento aquí no optimizado nada dejo todo por
defecto por ser uso de aterre para la salida para pasar vamos a poner true vale y le vamos a dejar
salido original fall salida en banda true y filtro vol filtro tren paso del vale vale pues
esto lo tengo ahora mismo en cinco minutos y opera mucho más porque ahora estoy en cinco minutos
lógicamente hay mucho más ruido y el mercado se sale muchas más veces de su banda pesar de ser
dos desviaciones y 14 y esto es perdido al 100 por ciento en el largo en el largo parece
asomar la cabeza parece asomar la cabeza pero en el corto es demolido lógicamente tiene el mercado
en contra pero bueno empezamos ya a operar un poco más vamos a ver qué pasa simplemente una
sencillísima y ligerísima optimización del stop vale del stop esto a este número de aterre se
imagino que será un valor alto aunque no tengo dudas pero lo vamos a resolver de seguida muy
breve esto no voy a hacer nada porque es sólo para evaluación preliminar evaluación preliminar
nada nada especialmente sacables para ver un poquito si el esto respira le da un poquito de
aire o no le hace nada vale bueno pues no sirve prácticamente no sé pero nada de hecho va mucho
peor con con esto pero aunque número de tres tiene muchos más de decir actúa demasiado alberto
es parece que no se viene bien ecualizado no con el aterre es todo supera lo mismo parece no
funcionar parece no funcionar a ver el 5 si ves te saca te saca todo el rato casi te saca casi todo
el rato oído oído espera que no sé si tengo el lift si lo tengo vale y porque saca tanto
está está debo ser un baque ayer debo ser un baque aquí en el con porque ese es con aterre
aterre el aterre está calculado si por el número de barras que tenga aterre a ver el
vale bien y siento de cero y esto aterre porque aquí no va por cien no sirva por ciento y es
puntos de divulgarlo pero si hacemos un cálculo rápido repuesto 10 por 5 10 por 5 claro lo
divido por 100 es super pequeño super pequeño no porque con el aterre no tiene sentido meter
la porción a ver creo puede ser que estés sonando la misma canción hace 74 horas alberto no no puede
ser una en el en el alexa o me lo parece mejor todas son iguales no yo tampoco pero las veces
que me fijo me da la sensación que suena siempre lo mismo ahora no salta nunca para perfecto le
hemos quitado dos decimales ahora yo creo que va a ser ya más normal no le quito uno entonces le
pongo dos pero es para ver solo si para ver solo se actúa pregunta franz con el guilliams y el
guilliams es un estocástico el guilliams es una pequeña o sea disculpa gracias pregunta fran
si guilliams porcentaje en franja central para activar operaciones puede ir bien guilliams es
un estocástico al final sí o sea cualquier indicador es un indicador también de de rango
podemos decir aunque también se puede usar en tendencias es que en la mayoría de esos
recomendados es explorarlo nosotros hemos operado un sistema de estocástico que es
muy parecido en tendencia vale con valores muy es muy duros es decir no con no con sus
valores muy elevados al final también puede puede funcionar y un williams puede utilizarse
del mismo manera de rango de tendencia pero sí sí es un buen indicador el guilliams es un buen
indicador tiene una pequeña variación de la memoria pero creo que tiene una pequeña variación
del estocástico simplemente es muy similar para aquí no sé si ahora hemos hecho algo no a ver
más que nada para entenderlo como el interior no lo he mirado pues es lo que lo que pasa bueno
ahora sí que se nota una variación de tres al menos vale se nota una una variación de
trades aquí se acerca pero aún no llega es decir a un 5 aún está saltando ves porque
tiene más tres que aquí es decir que aún le faltaría un poco pero bueno ya empieza a tener
más sentido sigue siendo una porquería pero pero tiene más más sentido no ninguno ninguno aporta
ninguna aporta no es curioso que no tenga ningún si el 5 parece ir mejor le faltaría un subir un
poco para quitar alguno no quitar alguno pero bueno es igual lo volvemos 5 y está es igual si
era por era por por verlo entonces era era por verlo era por verlo también es verdad que en 5
minutos pensar que el stop donde es más donde se nota más su efecto que os decía que se iba a
notar es en gráficos de más largo plazo porque en 5 minutos aún en con enganchadas su pérdida
entre tampoco es tan importante y el precio acaba volviendo de mucho más ruido aquí fíjate que ha
salido por por el bueno no ha salido pero hubiera salido ya en nada ha salido muy cerca hecho está
muy muy cerca de salirse aquí fijaros por poco no una pequeña corrección porque al final en 5
minutos hay tanto ruido que es más frecuente que hayan haya un movimiento a la contra suficiente
para cerrarle la banda contraria lo cerca que está normalmente la banda contraria ahora el diario eso
cambia totalmente el diario la banda contraria puede estar muy lejos entonces aunque lógicamente está
todo autoescalado hay más ruido en 5 minutos que al final esto acaba provocando que el esto muchas
veces no rente aquí por ejemplo renta el caso típico pero de manera general le cuesta le cuesta
que rente pero bueno que ahora sí habéis visto que estaba cerca de que de que rentar esto aquí en
5 minutos es muy complicado es muy complicado creo que podrías creo que podría conseguirse que
funcionara un 5 minutos con bolingar antitenencial creo que se podía conseguir creo que se podía
conseguir pero había que trabajarlo mucho seguramente con pautas con pautas de precio
habría que filtrar mucho que se habría que filtrar mucho a medida que bajas más de
time frame es más imprescindible el filtro entendés y también tienes menos problema en
usarlo porque fíjate aquí yo tengo en seis meses y tengo cuántos trechos
cuántos tengo tengo 1500 trechos y sólo estoy en seis meses entonces el problema de tres no
no tengo problema de tres no tengo entonces aquí yo tengo por ejemplo lo que os decía del simple
filtro de adeques mira voy a pasar bueno le voy a dejar le voy a dejar ese ese film le voy a dejar
ese stop y vamos a probar esto da por el número de adeques que filtraba aunque creo que no lo hemos
puesto como decía creo que no lo hemos puesto como decía pero aún así yo creo que puede ser
que aporte que aporte valor a ver que no creo que no lo hemos definido a ver para las entradas
a lo miro que me reduce mucho produce mucho produce muchísimo muchísimos muchísimos
straights y en todas las combinaciones todas las combinaciones reducen muchísimos
de ver cómo tengo puesto el filtro de detención si tenía que la de que fuera mayor que un nivel
para para habilitarlo bueno esto habría que trabajarlo bien y ya digo en cinco minutos lo bueno
para este tipo de nos puede venir bien para hasta estudiar el activo de acuerdo es decir el
antecedencial porque te va a dar mucha te va a dar mucha mucha información porque aunque la
entrada sea distinta la entrada tiendencial es bastante obvia en este caso es muy bastante
es bastante limpia de acuerdo a la entrada de mil reversión de bolinger bands porque
bolinger bands al final es un indicador lo explico al final simplemente es la de las
desviaciones sobre una media y por lo tanto ya sabes que recoge más del 90% el movimiento
del precio etcétera es decir está un indicador que está muy bien normalizado entonces al final
vender siempre en su banda es normalmente es vender en un nivel de desviación de precio muy
bueno y sus estudios suelen ser bastante extrapolables quiero decir es decir si ahora
aquí le pongo dos años y le hago un estudio al filtro del de la de que es en bruto es probable
que ese filtro me sirva para otro titendencial no sé si me estoy explicando en el nasa que
no no quiero decir que va a ser exacto pero es probablemente bastante extrapolable entonces
aquí os voy a hacer ahora una pequeña prueba
tenía dos cosas preparadas pero es que a mí no sé mejor mejor me equivoco pero yo es que creo
que esto es lo más chulo de esto no de ir moviéndonos por el gráfico probando cosas que
se me ocurre en este momento no os pensáis que que me lo invento que se me ocurre ahora porque
es que se me ocurre ahora tengo un montón de cosas preparadas un montón de waspays ahí listos como
veis como veis preparados para enseñaros de booty char de tal optimizaciones pero me he
liado con esto y me ha parecido interesante verlo entonces pues nada
le voy a quitar el esto a esta le voy a quitar el esto vamos a volver a jugar con el adx pero
le voy a le voy a hacer tres lo voy a probar tres combinaciones le ve filtro 3 le voy a probar 3
tres combinaciones para ver si me aporta esta manera de poner los filtros es la que conviento
mucho bueno en general porque así el cero se te queda se te queda dentro es decir usas que el
cero el cero si es cero no no trabaje lo pones aquí comentado vale lo hemos puesto por cierto y
ya está entonces le dices si es mayor que cero pan y si no es true y así y así no actúa entiendes
es una manera bastante bastante chula entonces es que me da la sensación que sobre todo entraría
va a aportar mejor al revés mira que te digo abierto aportar más al revés en lo que lo que
mira juventa cuantas antes que te decía de los mapas de no mirarlo ves si una manera de cuando
ya le tienes experiencia de mirar los mapas sin mirarlos se me entienda juego de palabra es en
vez de ordenarte las tablas por tsi por ppc por lo que quieras vale te lo ordenas por el input de
0 a 40 y así tu en tu mente haces el mapa tienes que de hecho en 2d también lo puedes hacer aquí
en 2d también lo puedes hacer aquí es cutre es cutre pero se puede es pero así ya lo ves
pues ya ves un poco el mapa es el mapa aquí es que de aquí que salta mucho pero es que aquí
pues hay una buena zona es que hay una buena zona en profit puedo mirar también el down aunque
está el dragón monetario pero aquí es aquí es poco importante aquí yo si pusiera un esto
monetario podría ir bien y no tendría problema porque estoy hablando de dos años que sí que
se mueve pero es más adaptable de acuerdo es más adaptable hay tanto movimiento de precio vale
entonces aquí por ejemplo en 8 me sabe tiene 2.000 operaciones pensar que con 0 voy con 5.000
la mitad vale pero veis cómo está portando es como está portando no está portando ahí tenemos
1500 1700 acuerdo está portando en en ese set up vale entonces ahora yo quiero aquí probar dos
cosas quiero eliminar la condición de que esté bajando todo esto lo podremos hacer suponiendo
que tres station no se cuelgue algo que ya os digo que es realmente muy poco probable porque cuando
vas cambiando haciendo esto se satura es una cosa muy desesperante se va perdiendo como se
cansara imagina vosotros vais subiendo la montaña pues igual es como si se cansara cuando llevas
mucho rato con él haciéndole casos cargándole gráficos de pronto va siendo cada vez más lento
más lento en serio lo cierras perfecto se va a tomar un repolo algo entonces va de lujo entonces
este es el tema entonces este es un filtro que repito estamos sólo investigando ahora mismo el
adx de acuerdo el adx porque tengo aquí una condición ahora estamos mirando que la de que
sea mayor que un nivel mayor que un nivel que sea mayor es decir eso que os digo para aumentar
la eficacia de entrada es buena pero es verdad que este tipo de filtros muchas veces son contra
contra intuitivos por lo que os decía antes no es mejor que no haya tendencia sí pero muchas
veces en muchos activos cuando no va a haber tendencias después de haber mucha tendencia
tendéis contracción expansión pero no se está mucho tiempo con la de que es bajo puede ser que
sí entonces esa es la es un poco la lauda y hay que hay que investigarlo entonces aquí volvemos
por cero y como veis la condición que le he quitado que está así que sospechaba quería
ver pero la tengo en bruto lo que le he añadido porque esta es la condición que la verdad que
esa no lo hemos visto en muchos en muchos autores la explico brevemente que aportaba bastante como
habéis visto es yo te digo que vaya alta yo te digo vale tú solo puedes comprar cuando la de
que se esté pero perdón comprar o vender da igual mayor de cierto nivel es decir cuando
está bajo de cierto nivel entiendo no no te dejo vale no quiero que quiero que estés que sea mayor
que era 16 y cuando está muy muy bajo no me interesa no me interesa entonces eso es como
está ahora pero ves ahora ya no acabo de aportar pero además le he añadido donde tengo otra
condición que es vale que estés alto pero que estés bajando de acuerdo es que estés bajando y
esa es la que ahora había quitado es es decir que la de que es actual sea menor que la de que es
anterior se ha dado un valor mayor es decir aquí por ejemplo bueno aquí era creo que salía 16 vale
para que para que veáis el nivel la de que es la que es igual que el sistema a ver que no sé si
lo tengo bien puesto espérate a no se va a dejar en 14 14 sólo lo hemos dejado igual 14
pero el disparador era 16 el que nos ha salido pero no vale para que entendáis la jugada es decir
decir cuando está que hacía el filtro vale que sólo puede sólo podría abrir sólo podría abrir
cuando estuviera por encima de la línea verde cuando está en azul cuando está en azul sólo
puede abrir por debajo no pero le añadimos el requisito que estuviera bajando y eso le
aportaba bastante eso le aportaba bastante de hecho ahora se lo voy a añadir directamente
así como veis bueno no sé si le dejaron valor puesto claro bueno como he visto que el 16 va
bien mira le pongo ahora el 16 le pongo a bueno se ha quedado en 20 me da igual vale
y en mente va como vaya vale y ahora si estamos en lo cierto añadirle la condición que se la
voy a esa condición se la voy a volver a añadir vale se la voy a se la voy a quitar le quito esto
vale que este menor ahora debería de mejorar va a recargar va a recargar y creo que sería
algo mejor ahora confío aunque igual salía de zona recordaros que ahora el nivel puede ser otro
puede ser otro pero principio a ver cuando recargue ha mejorado un poco ha mejorado un
poco todavía está ahí justito pero es que ha subido ha subido porque salen la zona un poquito
más más hasta aquí todo más más straight porque el éxito que esté que esté bajando este es un
poco ese es un poco el tema que os decía vale estos estos los intradía que son muy necesarios
pero hay bastante margen de investigación puedes tranquilamente jugar con ellos puedo
decir porque tienes muchos tres es mucha significación y puedes todo el rato jugar con
el filtro esto está bastante correcto y esto lo que hablaba antes hizo rubén con la librería
de filtros lo puedes hacer así lo puedes hacer así y en un entradía no tienes ningún problema
entonces ahora lo que vamos a invertir es la condición pero le voy a quitar la del más porque
sí que os confieso tener bastantes dudas sobre sobre en un en un entradía por lo que os decía
el ruido pero esa tendencia tan persistente a la lateralidad en los entradía donde es posible que
perdure el suficiente tiempo para que le rente filtrar al revés filtrar sólo a que esté para
debajo vale pues ahora esto así directamente ya está es positivo fijaros vale pero le vamos a
dar otra optimización al filtro a los diseño a los diseño que voy simplemente le he invertido
el signo ahora lo que voy a decirles que sólo puede abrir si está por debajo de la de que es
de esa manera aquí yo yo lo creo que puede mejorar evolucionando un poco y como os doy una
pista para que lo podemos tratar de sacarlo con el MRO es decir no sólo pidiéndole el MRO
sí para este tipo de cosas pero no pedirle una vela algo y le varias velas es una manera de
conseguirlo en las últimas cinco velas esté por debajo de cierto nivel por encima entonces
esa manera yo le puedo pedir una cierta persistencia de algo no que sólo me pasé en una vela como veis
como veis era bastante mejor el contrario que es el que aparentemente es contraintuitivo pero es
que ya os digo las pruebas que hace siempre acaba pasando tenía dudas aquí y no al final sigue
saliendo lo que lo que siempre sale lo que siempre sale que es por encima y con la volatilidad pasa
igual vale los mil reversión va mejor filtrando a en volatilidad es decir que puedan operar en
volatilidad alta porque porque a partir de ahí va a bajar ahí aumenta mucho el porcentaje de
aciertos es lo mismo que hemos visto aquí aquí le hemos pedido que sólo puede abrir si el ADX
es menor que cierto nivel y veis que nos está saliendo aquí 18 y tal se lo pongo aquí ahora
para que lo veáis es decir sólo puede operar por debajo 18 ahora es al revés es por debajo ahora
sólo puede operar con este rojo sólo puede operar con ese rojo por eso veis que no que sólo abre
a saber no puede no puede abrir y como veis pues va peor en cambio ahora simplemente para
que veáis el cambio ahora ya simplemente aunque sin el otro filtro cuidado porque
aquí no tengo no tengo el filtro también podía añadirle el filtro a ver pedirle que estuviera
dos bueno ya lo voy a empezar a abrirlo otro porque al final lo que lo que tenía listo lo
voy a enseñar de todos los que tenemos preparados pero bueno ahí lo tenéis ahí lo tenemos ahí
lo tenemos como a mejorar un poco más recordar que sólo hemos tocado el hemos tocado el ADX
pero ahora le hemos añadido que esté en negativo y entiendo que así va a empeorar bastante
esperaros lo quiero comprobar ahora debería dar peor el resultado os enseño es que todos
podemos ser un monitor a la vez y si enseño esto no se ve el gráfico no se ve tal entonces bueno
el gráfico de igual no más que más de que se va el gráfico ahora lo tenemos así es si
si era como como esperaba es infiltrado pero además añadiendo ley que esté subiendo o bajando vale
lo veis en el gráfico de hecho el nivel de trades así no no va a cambiar mucho es decir este pequeño
cambio veréis que volviendo al que estaba ahora no debería cambiar muchísimo el número de trades
vamos a 1000 1400 tenemos comisiones puestas ya sabéis que me gusta incluso la valoración
preliminar a ponerlo a pero sí que me baja mucho espera te espera te espera te que no he entendido
yo aquí que no he entendido bien yo aquí amigo claro claro claro porque en este nivel le cuesta
mucho cuidado porque en este nivel le cuesta mucho que estés menor y que estés bajando
aquí que más es bajando te pido claro ya le cuesta mucho ser bajando ahí me convence mucho
ese filtro me convence mucho me da la sensación que está sobreutilizado quitado así habría que
verlo habría que verlo que nos va a ir costando esto cargar un poco aprovecharé para hacer ahora
un momentito una pausita y así cierro el 3 session y es que os he dicho que os he dicho cuando tú
tienes un gráfico de intradía tienes que evitar acordaros cuando hablamos ahora un pequeño speed
de los míos pero creo que es importante acordaros no recuerdo el vídeo exacto pero cuando hablamos
de la de la de los datos de la muestra hablamos de dos características hablamos de representatividad
y hablamos de significación y os dije tener en cuenta que cuando yo tengo un intradía es muy
fácil tener significación pero no tanto tener representatividad hay que vigilar de no dejarse
llevar por eso decir hostia 4000 trades esto es la hostia esto es indestructible no no porque
ahora he dicho porque es lo que tenía antes tenía menos no porque al final sigo estando en
seis meses de mercado bueno lo que esté en dos años y si esos dos años están muy sesgados
respecto a la muestra y el mercado cambia por más que tenga no se va a comportar igual se entiende
entonces el diario es un poco al revés yo tengo mucha representatividad es decir realmente lo he
evaluado en muchos tipos de mercado por la teoría creciente de creciente alcista bajista lateral
pensionista de todos los tipos a lo mejor tengo menos trade pero tengo un análisis de tipos de
mercado muy representativo de lo que es él y es más probable que se sostenga en el tiempo se
entiende si no es sobreutilizado siempre en cambio en la intradía yo me es muy fácil encontrar
significación y esto es muy representativo pero si a lo mejor me quedo muy poco tiempo de mercado
me he adaptado mucho a un estilo de mercado gente que le gusta hacer eso y en las técnicas más
adaptativas etcétera se juega más eso vale es decir ahí porque porque al final yo me voy
autoregulando el algoritmo va entrenando de acuerdo y la lógica o la teoría hace hace esto
de manera permanente se va entrenando con los datos en principio más recientes aunque no tienen
también pueden ser históricos pero pero digamos que lo más reciente lo va incorporando y por lo
tanto va haciendo una adaptación a esos cambios entonces es importante que quede claro entonces
aquí ahora se ha roto tanto pero porque seguramente lo que tenía cargado no era representativo de lo
que le he cargado luego de acuerdo y simplemente hemos ido a tomar viento pero es correcto es decir
no quiere decir que no que no esté bien mirarlo mirarlo y aquí ahora por ejemplo pues para
simplificar ahora vamos a analizar el filtro en bruto ahora otra vez sin mayor o menor de acuerdo
filtro bruto adx menor o adx mayor para que vaya un poco más rápido le voy a hacer de 3 en 3 menos
y esto un poquito menos y ya sabe que le he metido cinco años en vez de dos pero tenemos muchísimas
más barras vale y casi que mira aprovecho hago los cinco minutos de pausa mientras trabaja bueno
lo preparo para la siguiente porque esto una vez empieza a arrancar fácil me lo preparo
para la siguiente poder hacerlo así haré una pequeña pausita un momentito que iré a visitar
así roca y cuando acabe la opti sacaré las conclusiones y lo y reiniciaré que si era un
poco más acabamos esto acabamos esto ya y acabas que esto una vez empezaba más lo quería hacer en
multicharts todo esto pero no sé por qué me le iba a hacerlo aquí de verdad porque
muchas es un poquito más rápido y lo tengo preparado pero bueno es que soy así yo es
pero no sería yo entonces claro no sería lo mismo sería mejor sería peor pero no sería distinto
hemos quedado sin tres he hecho así así va mejor no pero y es perfecto es ha decidido no operar y
está perfecto es el mejor mejor es no operar si vas para casa le pones una de x de 6 no
operas y es como va mejor el sistema de razón de otra cosa de cinco minutos es muy complicado
os lo digo que lo normal es que haya que filtrar por pautas a bueno una cosa que no estamos haciendo
casi casi imprescindible en un intradía de cinco minutos la gracia es que tengo un código que
permite hacerlo eso es lo que tiene más delito de verdad porque tengo un código que permite hacerlo
pero yo estoy usando uno que no lo permite porque como os digo así para que es filtrar
ventanas horarias ventanas horarias es ver y ver importantes entonces al final yo no lo estoy
haciendo pero pues si no lo intentaré hacer ahora lo dejo le pongo la pausa y reinicio y cuando
arranque arranco con otro lo miro en el otro también alberto me podías avisar igual podías
avisar que tengo el otro código intradía pongo este ahora pongo este ahora a igual y si que
mejor va a ir seguro porque francamente era fácil y le doy al relojito vale el relojito
que ya pausita de cinco minutitos bien pues ya estamos de vuelta tras este breve
descansito que he aprovechado para visitar a un amigo tenía ahí y de a poner que ya acaba por
ahora y y ya está entonces pues nada mientras había visto así que esto con tantos tres y tal
no aporta así no no queda claro cual aporta pero bueno de momento lo voy a dejar así es como creo
yo que o sea que sea mayor y que la de kicks actual sea menor que antes si lo dejo así
ahí no he mirado perdón no he mirado bueno esto es lo que lo pienso de un segundo por
tanto cargar al servicio pero pasé el paso mientras no tendré el bueno miramiento es
vez con los multichars aquí no he hecho nada antes ahora todo si que he hecho algo si que he hecho
algo si lo guardo guardo es algo ya de este porque aquí que tengo aquí si el multichar se está
yendo abajo esto que valor tengo el puesto el filtro aquí 30 nápolos demasiado alto vamos a
probar una cosita rápida lo voy a dejar en una zona más o menos de equilibrio que es 20
menos equilibrio que es 20.b n más o menos de equilibrio que es 20 toco este bien perfecto
pues ya como suponíamos este es el bueno así ha salido bueno antes pero si a lo que no me
haces y también solo si si porque así no filtra así no filtra simplemente superando esta
es ahora sí sí distintas combinaciones del mayor o menor que la de x y cayendo bajando simplemente
ahora solo esa es la original es la que teníamos entre la de x mayor y cayendo es la es la original
la que teníamos entrada vale si hemos llegado al mismo sitio simplemente que viendo el gráfico
he querido evaluar otra otra cosa y ya está pero no me haces como queda y si ahora le quito esto
es imposible aparte y así lo dejaré guardado el código de cómo ya como ya está esto alberto
puntate por favor mañana hacer el de esos códigos que ahora veremos el paper todo el pdf todo esto
el código y tal ahí vamos para que cargue y lo ciego si lo guardo y es que no vamos un
momentito a media horita vamos a abrir ya las dos cositas que teníamos o tres preparadas
a ver tengo que abrir todo lo ciego y que se ciove todo de 3d station ya está bien si
el diario que voy a abrir el multichars se ve la batalla ahora ahora ahora se me ha salido
que había un conflicto ahora lo veo bueno aquí tenemos el original y tenemos un poco todo no
curiosamente gana en el corto solo con 1 a 1 ahí filtrando filtrando si es hemos hecho una
se hemos hecho ese es el original que habéis visto ahora lo único que es en diario y tiene
filtro el filtro de creo que era el día de que solo lo tenía implementado también se lo hemos
puesto porque ellos en el paper que ya os he comentado que los haremos al final
da unas sugerencias no dice bueno sugerencias de mejora tal como se tal tal tal tal la tendencia
tal por lo tanto dice bueno lo mismo que hay que vigilar el comprar reiteradamente en una
tendencia bajista o viceversa es filtrar los stage cuando hay una tendencia fuerte detectada
y relajando los criterios de entrada cuando su porto resistencia y soportes liberos se
empieza a aparecer entonces bueno pues ahí hay un poco de camino a seguir y bueno pues
habíamos implementado esto de la de aquí entonces aquí en su versión original que ahora ya estamos
en la otra pues simplemente le metimos dejamos el código puesto ahí original pero añadimos
una variable como filter vale que dijimos bueno y un stop vale porque ven decían ellos de ponerlo
lo puse monetario para el fácil y está y filter pues que lo mismo si es cero pues se activa el
filtro este de la de que es mayor que el filtro y que esté cayendo que es el que habíais visto ahora
vale y aquí pues se aprecia de cero a bien como bueno si que tiene una zona de cierta de cierta
mejora vale sin ser tampoco muy radical porque los valores bajos lógicamente no actúa empieza
a actuar aquí en 10 pero ya se sube mucho más pues de grada pero bueno sé que tiene aquí una
cierta mejora muy pequeñita muy pequeñita de hecho ya con cero también da buenos valores sobre todo
en el en el lado corto sobre todo en el lado curiosamente curiosamente donde da mejores valores
en la corte recordar que este promedio que se promedio bien si vamos al siguiente aquí ya
estamos en las versiones que hemos trabajado de manera normal podríamos haber puesto también el
día que se pensó en una cadenita así guapa vale bueno aquí tenemos vamos a ver antes lo que lo
que tenemos aquí tenemos un churro patotero tenemos un churro patotero aquí tenemos
algo decente y aquí tenemos algo de centillo más bien en el lado en el lado largo a ver qué
tenemos por aquí a eso con 34 bueno esto con un valor muy largo con esto con tp bueno que lo hemos
utilizado un poco todo no alberto pero no es usada salida contraria aquí entiendo que si no
exactamente salida con banda aquí salimos con banda y metiendo stop vale y allí le has puesto
tp y stop sin banda perfecto muy bien pero con la media muy larga no media 34 dos desviaciones y
demás ella muy larga media muy larga bueno esta es lo que lo que os digo a quería había que
explorar el camino como os decía de los de los filtros vale hay que explorar el camino de los
filtros pero sobre todo en el lado largo lógicamente en el corto es más difícil pero
también se pueden se pueden sacar como veis se pueden explorar distintos distintos caminos
sobre todo por el vía de filtrado vale a mí en el diario como os decía me cuesta más me cuesta
más pero bueno sí que abordaría intentaría explorar el camino de filtrar bien de que es
bien volatilidad de acuerdo bien volatilidad se puede hacer por varios caminos aquí no está
filtrado ahora varios caminos el que hemos implementado aquí es no muy sencillo pero
hay otros vale también vía vía figuras de congestión expansión poco lo que vimos en el
que acordaros que allí sí que montemos un que os acordáis montamos un montamos un que
es con el revés de este tipo de esto que decíamos con las setups te estaba hablando ahora que me
acuerdo si estás todavía rubén del de la de la teoría y teníamos un ejemplo bastante más cercano
esto que era todo esto no este no era debe ser uno tampoco era este este este este este vale este
que yo creo que lo enseñamos esto no teníamos aquí veis todo un switch este es el caso ejemplo
eso con el reveló lo enseñamos de distintos filtros que vimos en las revistas acordáis
este es el lo que hablaba rubén de los filtros exactamente esto de aquí tenemos 19 casos para
probar distintas elementos lo único que es lo que yo os decía aquí no metería de más optimizaría
la media tal sabes decir se complica poco todo vamos a forzarlo demasiado pero probar distintas
pautas de precio así para ver cómo se mueve y si puede ser distintos activos vale porque la idea
debería de ser bastante extrapolable para que cada activo tiene su comportamiento pero pero
deberían de ser filtros del mismo estilo y muy muy similares en activos similares y básicamente
los distintos no pero esto es un poco con los con los es un plano plot que esos son los show me para
ver las velas que se cumple un determinado caso entonces con esto luego en el sistema pues podemos
usar uno podemos usar otro en su acordar es que eso lo vimos entonces esto proviene un poco de
ese de esa idea que hablamos antes con cuando vemos más señales de entrada más evaluamos
entrar pues lo haremos de esta manera porque es la manera más rápida hacerlo vale todo lo que os
decía los fitos los hemos implementado estos dos pero el camino es infinito el camino hemos probado
adx hemos probado volatilidad y mirando solo el porcentaje de volatilidad que no sea mayor que
cierto nivel y que esté bajando junto simplemente es muy sencillo vale la volatilidad se puede
explorar por muchos caminos como os decía como simplemente el concepto de contracción expansión
no directamente una sino una figura que indique contracción que indica contracción pues el rango
bajando como vimos en el rv el rango más pequeño una insight bar también los filtros con tal que no
sea un día volátil que no sea un día de rango muy elevado el anterior cosa sino que eso es un
poco lo que lo que miramos con este con el normalizado pero que hay distintas maneras de
buscar un poco lo mismo el camino es bastante infinito aquí ahora mismo tenemos cargado desde
el 99 al 24 y ya digo aquí habría que explorar brevemente pequeño filtro y es lo último que
hago aquí para irme a multichars si esto es el bolingero del 34 me parece que lo alberto de un
artículo mío bastante antiguo donde hice un análisis antitenencial así con tres medias
fáciles en muchos activos y vimos muchos que iban que van bien esto lo podemos buscar alberto
está por ahí me ha acordado está por ahí si buscas boling en artículos en la carpeta de
marketing te sale seguro y lo publicó no sé qué revista no me acuerdo en cuál nos lo publicaron
y estaba estaba todo es antiguo pero pero bueno pues sirve y era era simplemente muy muy muy
sencillo este es el mismo filtro que hemos hecho antes ponemos 40 de 2 en 2 bueno esto como el
no porque va a tardar entiendo que bastante poco va a tardar bastante poco bueno pues
nada más lo que pensaba pensaba que sería más rápido va a tardar un minuto pero pero pensaba
que sería bueno pues nada no aporta ciertamente nada para mí que debe estar al revés el filtro
otra vez porque si no parece demasiado heavy no debe estar al revés del filtro cuál cuál he
mirado el filtro tren el trotren trotren luego yo me he hecho que es todo más sencillo con esas
cosas bien aquí tenemos y te va a ver en el día tenemos otra versión que es basada en esta también
vale partiendo de la misma pero añadiendo alguna alguna evolución más que hemos comentado brevemente
luego ya lo lo miraremos de demostrar el día siguiente y el paper y demás que la siguiente
clase intentaremos hacer otra cosa porque si no no avanzamos pero que ya mostrarémos un poco mejor
vale porque nos va a dar del todo del todo tiempo pero que es que es lo mismo de acuerdo es decir no
no hay no hay cambios queríamos ver un poco toda la curva para que vierais que cambios puede tener
un diario de un de un entradía al final la banda de bowling es igual funciona igual funciona
muy bien el entradía antes hemos ya hemos visto una prueba de cinco minutos de que funciona muy
bien que daba buenas entradas es un buen setup de entrada porque entradía el mercado de equity
tiene bastante a la reversión y por lo tanto va bien el tema es lo que decía y hay que filtrar
en el entradía así que hay que filtrar hay que buscar unos filtros de mucho camino para
para explorarlo y cuáles hemos mostrado aquí de entrada bueno hemos programado los dos que
habéis visto lo único que hemos incorporado otro data para hacerlo en base diario para no hacerlo
en el mismo en el mismo entradía es decir analizar un poquito cuál es la volatilidad general de este
mercado y la tendencia general de este mercado vale se puede referir al mismo data si también
podías hacerlo con el mismo data vale pero bueno hemos querido incorporarlo así para pasarnos
más en la tendencia de fondo del activo es una manera de mirar a otros días podría hacerse
también buscando pautas del día anterior usando bien sin usar el data 2 porque ni si
ya sabéis que está el close de el close de es el cierre diario el cross week es el cierre
semanal el close es el cierre mensual vale eso en un entradía te puedes referir a cualquier vela
diaria usando esto y lo mismo para el high para el low para open vale yo puedo hacer open daily
es el open diario es decir todos los cuatro precios están construidos con arrays yo puedo
llamarlos o usarlos en el gráfico entradía pero la manera más sencilla para que no se
hagan muchos problemas es usar esto el data 2 en diario pero yo podría haber hecho un cálculo
diario sin llamarlo usando casi meter el data 2 recuerdo si meter el data 2 utilizando estos
campos del close de ejemplo el close de oja y de lo que era y lo mismo para figuras de velas
o sea pautas de pautas de precio como hablamos en un site de un narrow range lo vimos para
los revés todo esto sigue perfectamente aplicable vale yo puedo valorar entrar o no
mil reversión dependiendo de si el día anterior o los días anteriores hubo mucha tendencia poca
tendencia mucha volatilidad poca volatilidad y una manera de mirar mucho eso es los rangos
vale ya vimos usando range recordar que ranges hike menos low y también los cuerpos de las velas
puedes usar que es open menos close o close menos open vale esas comparaciones que son las figuras
de velas podemos decir pues de los campos de la que define a una vela open o una barra open
close high low pues te dan te dan juego para definir los rangos entonces el código tiene
esto prácticamente igual aquí entra un poco el tema horario vale el tema horario una función
que calcula las la sesión que nosotros definimos vale nuestro horario que decimos abrir posición
esto en el intradía como os decía es bastante habitual y casi obligatorio vale casi obligatorio
para una entradía al puro es verdad que si vamos sobre todo pensando en breakout y en
breakout sea open red breakout o ahora mil reversión que es un poco el lado contrario vale ya vamos en
tendencia pura es más complicado no digo que no se pueda no digo que no se pueda pero es un poco
más complicado porque porque al final en un tendencia pura que al final va a ser casi un swing yo
puedo estar varios días comprado que se entran y entonces en la hora que compre no es tan importante
acuerdo al final donde es importante filtrarle el horario sobre todo si yo no voy a estar dentro
del mercado demasiado tiempo me acuerdo entonces yo quiero maximizar mis oportunidades y por lo tanto
es muy claro que los mercados tienen estacionalidad en todos los mensuales diarios y por supuesto
diarios suelen tener ciertas pautas de comportamiento que pueden utilizarse para
maximizar mis entradas de acuerdo es decir yo sé que el mercado habitualmente hay unas horas que
suele estar tranquilo pues a lo mejor a mí para esas horas no me sirven para operar o si me sirven
para mi reversión que hay que jugar un poco con ello y analizarlo y también por supuesto vía
optimización entiendo que este código alberto está preparado para optimizar el horario no
porque bueno para utilizar tiene su particularidad pero al final este código respecto al otro lo que
decía plantea básicamente está esta diferencia tiene aquí un código tiene una función que le
habilita para operar en caso de que esté dentro de su horario si no pues no puede abrir además
también tenemos el alaulón al uso que no lo he explicado antes pero tenemos un true osor para
decir sólo largos sólo cortos si quisiera para trabajar un lado sólo y además bueno tiene lo que
tenía el otro acuerdo la misma entrada aquí ya directamente hemos planteado sólo el cruce vale
se puede meter el mro para usar más de un día del final el mro recordar que lo único que ha
es que puedo evaluar varias velas que sé por debajo lo hemos dejado así para que veáis la
otra manera directa este es el cruce más típico de la manera de entrar más típica de bollinger en
anti tendencia es esta vale que el cierre cruce para arriba la banda de abajo vale en ese caso yo
voy largo y que cruce para abajo la banda de arriba en ese caso voy corto además tengo los filtros
que ya habéis visto antes que hemos jugado un poco con ellos y poco más la salida original que
tenía el otro sistema bueno esta no es la original original alberto esta es la una variación que
tenían ellos te la voy a copiar lo mismo salida por stop y tp no trailing con atr notr en por
centaje que este módulo pues ya lo habéis visto en muchos muchos códigos vale vamos a ver que
tenemos por aquí todavía estamos cargando bueno pues nada tú a tu vuelo me abro el telesecho que
creo que sí que lo tengo cargado tampoco lo tendré pues vamos pues me pasa por no haberlo abierto
antes este que es el diario no lo no lo he abierto antes y ahí está pues dale que te va que se lo
abro ahora entre este eso no creo que me vaya rápido abierto bueno tengo este abierto aquí de
momento vamos a trabajar previamente previamente este que ya lo ya lo habéis visto la única la
única gracia que tiene multichars que es bastante más rápido de optimizar y es verdad que para hacer
pequeñas pruebas así a nivel de valoración preliminar viene bien a mí no me gusta que no tenga
la chanpele no me gusta es decir que no te permita dejar a chanpele como te deja tres
a sacar los datos ahí en tres hojas no me gusta mucho esa metodología y aquí pues no te permite
lo tienes que hacer tú aparte entonces su poco es un poco más rollo bueno sí que te permite hacer
luego el world forward y la matriz pero en una regular vale si ya puedo hacer esta cual forward
y al final pues no deja de ser si lo depende cómo lo configure pues no puedo dejar una especie de
optimización normal pero estaría bien aquí que te dejará poner autosample luego también tienes
la matrix vale la más compleja pero a mí en esta me gustaría que me dejara me dejara más acceder
a esto que es donde alberto ha optimizado antes a menos de esto creo y esto sigue sí sí sí esto
sigue esto sigue eso sí paciencia es esto sí que me gusta bastante en multichars que por ejemplo
puedes ver la curva de largo la curva de cortos bastante puedes ver juntarlo separado pues a
nivel del performance por esta está más chulo ya ven como no que le puedas meter el fitness que
quieras que puedas meter el fitness que quieras aquí que tenemos puesto el 1 control control
control de 4 es el de 4 es un poco largo no lo has probado en 14 a ver fall true por
el 0 0 0 y filtro stop te ha salido 2 y medio se ha optimizado no ya pero no se medio pues
vamos a ver vamos a ver qué nos da y en dos y medio cuidado que nos ha metido un corto ayer
ya que nos ha metido un corto ayer y va bien el también que es decir en la barra espera que aclare
porque no me carga por eso aberto se ha muerto está por aquí está por aquí
esto bueno esto como veis no lo quiero mucho hay una zona donde parece rendir algo que es muy poco
pero bueno recordar que está por por defecto el por defecto no es porque es 20 de hecho porque
le he puesto 14 bueno por la costumbre de las de los indicadores probablemente por defecto
bowling eres es 20 por defecto bowling eres 20 así que vamos a ver ahora parecido parecido parecido
así que aquí pues bueno quizá tener algún que tan cercano pero que pida tener una zona es lo que
decía el mapa pues al final tú lo ves un poco ahí lo mismo que verlo así en una zona donde es
bastante estable y tiene una cierta componente de actuación bastante alto porque mete muchos más
muchas más operaciones entonces bueno podías dejarlo por aquí podías dejarlo por aquí habría
que habría que verlo en esas dos zonas podría a lo mejor trabajar un poquito el nivel esto de la
zona del 2 vamos a dejar de momento esta vamos a dejar de momento esta y ahora vamos a probar el
filtro vamos a probar el de por atilidad pues están porcentaje no entiendo por lo tanto debería
de filtro gol el data 2 no tienes oculto alberto entiendo no a no coño si es el diario de la vida
esto es porcentaje no a ver todos y entonces el con tres ya debe ir muy bien es ahí no que
utiliza los dos sin querer sin querer utilizar los dos se quiere optimizar los dos ahí se
utiliza los dos me he equivocado se lo quería dejar en dos uno y ahora este lo activo así vamos allá
y estoy utilizando así estoy utilizando por sortino no lo he mirado antes que me decías que
me va a pasar bueno aquí empezamos a filtrar a filtrar a filtrar y bueno pues sí que parece
no pero filtra mucho el tra muchísimo el tra muchísimo el tra muchísimo quizá aquí sí que
igual valdría la pena a explorarlo sin sin añadirle la segunda condición no estamos todo el
rato con 13 y de fitness que nos ha dado más mira 0 13 6 0 13 6 me gusta más que sortino 0 13 6 y
aquí el bolo ahora se lo voy a quitar se lo voy a quitar porque para el bolo no me gusta tanto la
condición 0 13 6 eso es que va tan rápido que me queda igual perfecto muy bien se queda igual
porque lo he modificado en easy language pero es claro no no no no es lo que se dice una gemitada
es el tal no me cierra porque no me cierra esto tengo abierto alguno utilizado por un lado aquí
pero lo he cambiado en tres eso lo he cambiado tres no funciona entonces no lo que he hecho es
quitar este segundo componente de acuerdo porque volatilidad es donde nada que sí que
le veo más aquí tengo bastantes dudas tengo bastantes dudas y creo que aquí puede ser que
vaya más en bruto entonces ahora vamos a ver igual mismo filtro antes tan 0 13 6 parecido muy
parecido muy parecido algo mejor parece era 0 3 o 0 11 pues pues era mejor pero filtra menos
es que de la otra manera me filtra mucho para mi gusto demasiado y más en un diario pero sí que
aquí ves y que consigue algo menos algo mejor el resultado aunque tiene el peor peor pero
sortino pero aquí sí que parece el traer un poco aquí no sigue siendo bastante bastante justita la
cosa bastante justita la cosa pero bueno está yo algo mejor algo mejor sufre mucho en esta primera
parte hasta el 2008 en el lado largo luego pues ya va mejor simplemente aguanta me pasa que en el
corto tampoco acaba de aprovecharlo no acaba de aprovecharlo del todo no acaba de aprovecharlo
del todo a ver si me ha cargado esto bueno ya ha cargado ya ha cargado perfecto pero si al menos
podemos darle un vistazo rápido y que sea ni que sea tenemos un vistazo rápido aquí a la versión
que os decía del lado del lado corto vale ahí perdón del lado de intradía entonces aquí bueno
ya ya el código es lo enseñado antes antes aquí simplemente tenemos este ese por un lado
pasando parecido al otro si os habéis fijado a lo mejor tiene alguna función mal o algo pero 0 sin
esto para terrín 15 por sols y banda true y las horas 15 38 te ha quedado es que no se guarda
las optis aquí tío a ver si lo puedo abrir aquí era este ahora que acabó el otro a ver si se abre
este aquí aquí sé que tengo la base de datos creo ya bajada es vale es que yo creo que tenemos
algo mal tenemos a lo mejor el bueno la primera parte también va justo pero no da lo mismo puede
ser que la función del tiempo no es igual o que no o que no le hayas metido change acuérdate que
las funciones de tiempo son bastante sensibles a eso que no sé que el local o algo no está
en el change pues no sé que no tiene los mismos tres que se está operando aquí este no bueno ya
lo miraremos porque la gracia de multichars porque lo puedes ver separado vale lo puedes ver lo
aquí tenemos 123 está muy filtrado son 10 años últimos 10 años están todos los casos muy
muy filtrado es el mismo los tres tengo el mismo pero los tres si aquí tienes la hora que has
utilizado la sesión la sesión pues no filtra filtra mucha que mirar un poquito más de un poquito más
de histórico haría que mirar un poquito más histórico porque está tenemos muy poco estrecha
y bueno vamos a ir preguntaba jose por el tema de optimizar el frame no no me consta que haya una
una forma ni sencilla ni complicada se me ocurre de hacerlo ni en uno ni en otro no alberto el
multichars tampoco no se me no se me ocurre optimizarlo directamente si creo que ninja
tiene esa esa capacidad bueno es una herramienta más puede puede puede estar bien no digo que no
tampoco me volvería loco con ellos lo que te digo al final utilizando utilizando pues es lo que
hablamos siempre más más riesgo de todo no pero me gusta me gusta más que como me gusta más como
prueba de estrés como prueba de estrés lo veo bastante bueno de hecho me gusta mucho me gusta
mucho probar a mejor barras parecidas sabes un al lado y tal y ir viendo a ver cómo como degradar
el sistema igual que haces un mapa de optimización de los parámetros pues lo mismo en el tefe como
prueba de estrés me gusta bastante me gusta bastante más que el hecho de optimizar a ver
cuál va mejor como prueba de estrés sí que le veo bastante potenciales vale y bueno a ver a lo
largo de la semana tratamos de daros los códigos os voy a subir todo el estat estat lo pondré ahí
todo como material enterito a ver cómo lo subo porque es un montonazo de documentos pero os
subiremos en material todo el código del estat bueno este lo subiré con él con el que volen que
y tal vale entonces paper bollinger o sea el paper trading y todo todo el pdf bueno ya va a punto pdf
bolinger y y hasta luego lo que lo que nos había pedido por ahí que lo crea jose también en el
disco hay que hay que mirarlo a ver qué faltaba y demás vale y entonces veremos la semana que
viene trataremos de de acabar este bueno de acabarlo de dejarlo de dejarlo un poquito más
más maqueados con alguna con alguna combinación más más aprovechables solamente le haremos
alguna optimización y demás poco más seria más que esto esto esto que hemos hecho encaja
en la evaluación preliminar por el poquito de mirar investigar de cientos activos tal
pero por donde se mueve probar filtros probar horario que ahora no hemos podido mucho y a
partir de ahí quedaría pues ya evaluarlo un poco un poco mejor pero sobre todo al entraría faltan
filtros en el en los diarios sí que algo se puede filtrar pero no filtraría mucho más aquí sí que
hay que trabajar mejor los filtros probablemente añadiendo alguno como se decía de pauta de precio
alguna de pauta de precio que identifique un poco las contracciones y expansiones porque al
final en entraría es lo que lo que os explicaba es un poco lo que lo que explicaba hay que buscar
maximizar un poquito las oportunidades y que aquí parece que está yendo bastante bien pero a nivel
de salidas pues en alguna enganchada que no está mal por ejemplo hay que ver hay que ver cómo
conseguimos solucionar estas enganchaditas pues esta es la típica entrada de entrada que deberías
evitar que parece que viene con incremento de volatilidad es lo que lo que os decía es esta
este es el típico comportamiento que a veces no funciona vez tras esto normalmente hay tendencia
pero aquí fíjate tras esto normalmente contracción y en cambio de tendencia se la pega que nunca
que nunca hay garantías nunca hay garantías siempre es una parte contraria pero bueno ya
digo más veces después de contracción y expansión y viceversa es un poco lo que hay que lo que hay
que jugar pero ves está este equipo porque aquí no sé si al final tenemos esto pero aquí hay que
conseguir algún esto un poco más poco más eficaz aquí no hay esto todavía no
no hay esto para que el huerto no me sale el esto ha sido aquí aquí perdón aquí no hay esto
aquí seguramente a lo mejor un simple esto ya nos nos mejora un poquito la cosa nos mejora
un poquito la cosa y se queda ya más apañado porque realmente claro sigue teniendo el problema
de las de las enganchadas pero es aquí ya os digo habría que definir zona horaria habría
que trabajar algún filtro por supuesto bajar a un esto sería un poquito en el lo que quedaría
que en el en el intradía y yo creo que podemos conseguir algún algún set metaversión bastante
aprovechable partiendo de boling hermanas entonces enseñaremos lo que hayamos conseguido de cara
al día siguiente y le daremos la vuelta de acuerdo le daremos la vuelta y trabajaremos
porque esto sí que lo dije en la teoría le daremos el boling hermanas tendencial haremos el lado
el lado totalmente contrario vale idealmente idealmente pero no sé si podremos será combinarlos
para ver un poquito el qué tal trabajo hacen junto un sistema partiendo de la del mismo indicador
pero utilizando pues exactamente una operativa casi contra casi no totalmente contraria entonces
ahí si lo consigues en otro activo podéis ver que puede ser una diversificación bastante aceptable
bastante aceptable solamente dos estrategias solamente dos estrategias pero hay que primero
conseguir esta y luego conseguir la tendencia la familia pues nada más no veo más preguntas
no tengo nada marcado verdad alberto donde a la última se comenta que sí que utiliza la
utilización del también para la prueba de estrés pero también para ver dónde va mejor bueno ya te
digo si no no hombre entiendo que al final es una información que te puede te puede servir
pero tendría que tendría que mirarlo poco con con calma pero para ver en qué tipo va mejor está
bien está está está bien lo veo no lo veo mal también pues nada más familia hasta en principio
el martes que viene de acuerdo os veo a ver que pongo la caraturita para que quede así
grabado más chachi y por mi parte nada más hasta pronto chao